I'm excited to announce some new tour
date uh Toronto Ontario Canada on August
25th and 26th at Meridian Hall uh get
tickets with pre-sale code Rat King
starting Wednesday March 15th at 10 A.M
Eastern
Standard Time General on sale starts
Friday March 17th at 10 A.M eastern time
and as always patreon uh you guys will
get first crack at them uh today
um I want to let you know we're going to
be coming everywhere I'm trying to add
dates as often as I can and get to as
many different locations including
um the United Kingdom and other places
Australia
um everywhere America everything
um Canada as well we also have a few
tickets left in Medford Massachusetts
April 1st New York City May 14th Las
Vegas July 1st Uncasville Connecticut
Uncasville
and Atlantic City on July 23rd get your
tickets and all of them through
theovan.com
t-o-u-r for the return of the Rat tour
and uh just thank you guys so much in
advance for just making my dreams come
true I'm really excited about the show
today's guest is an NFL tight end for
the San Francisco 49ers uh he's an
All-Pro four-time pro bowler he is
hype he is hype uh he's uh he's he's
this he's the Savage masseuse
he's Captain violence himself today's
guest is Mr George Kittle
yeah I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
I just got out of the iceborn so hold on
I go for 10 minutes
10 minutes how cold
um now that's kind of the negotiable
part I think I agree with you I go for
right now I'm at 50. oh yeah dude for
sure I think if you're if you're under
like 50 degrees to like 40 I think
you're doing a really good job Yeah Yeah
well yeah because some guys it's like
they want to get as cold as they can
they like want to like they just want to
be so cold and they want to just like be
like I'm the coldest guy you know
congratulations yeah
yeah sure
yeah congratulations right like you're
not yeah if you want to be that cold
then move to like the North Pole or
something but don't just pretend you're
like the you're [__] Santa you know
just because you're in your garage do we
have at uh San Francisco we have two ice
subs and one's at 39 degrees the other
one's at like 45. yeah I'm in the four
like the 39 degree that's like what are
we doing that's what Bosa does all the
time yeah he likes that one he loves
being cold but like my pool in
California it's it's not heated and so
by mid-october it's like it's like 52
and then by the time you get to halfway
through November it's like 46 and I just
jump in every morning at 6 30 a.m oh wow
it's awesome great way to start your day
yeah yeah it definitely changes my whole
perception it kind of takes me out of my
brain I notice and puts me into my body
for sure dude I love it I just jump
right in you're in it for I mean I
usually do like three three to five
minutes I'm ready to roll for the whole
day oh really yeah that's about all I
need yeah I do like there's days like if
I ever recovery day because like most
time like I have to leave my house by 7
A.M else I don't make the meetings and
stuff like that so and I don't really
want to wake up at I mean six I like
don't like to wake up before six because
as soon as you see like a five on your
alarm clock it sucks yeah there is
something about that I think that makes
you be like oh what's going on here like
I'm a senior citizen or something
like they like that five you know oh
dude it's Sarah I was talking to Taylor
one today he was like yeah my workout
started at 5am I was like why
that's great yeah why especially if
you're just gonna get hurt every year
and not even play
oh well maybe
maybe this is his change maybe he's
doing something different yeah you know
Hey Taylor he'll be healthy man he'll be
fine he's got a couple tough breaks it's
a it is what it is yeah it is some of it
I think is his attitude gets stuck in
his knees to him [__] ruins him there
is something about when you get hurt you
definitely overthink about it both from
your recovery standpoint and then once
you get back onto the football field
like that's all you can think about like
just don't do it again just don't do it
again and the second you start thing
like that that's when it happens again
have you noticed that because you had a
what you had a break right I broke my
foot in 2020 yeah cuboid it's like up
here yeah then I so I was I came back in
five weeks and then the next like five
practices all that's all you can think
about and it sucks and then you go
through a whole offseason then you kind
of forget about it but still you get
back into football it's still what
you're thinking about like just don't
break it again and then like after a
while you just get comfortable and you
just forget about it were there routes
and stuff that you would adjust and not
do because you just to take the pressure
off just like planting really hard on it
it kind of just freaks me out a little
bit because the way I broke it too
didn't really make any sense I just kind
of got hit when my foot was in the
ground and it just kind of gave out so I
was just kind of more cautious more
careful like picking up my feet when I
was getting hit and stuff like that but
then like it's a bone it heals take a
lot of collagen drink a lot of milk it
is what it is yeah
um today by the way thanks man I feel
pretty good I think getting in that ice
plunge it does it Alters my perception
it Alters my perspective you know it's
like we're talking about that that's
what I'll it's like I notice if I'm in
like kind of a rough mood or I'm kind of
like
I want to feel a little bit more
kind of in my body if I'm just too much
in my head I'm like I want to get in my
body and I want to and I don't want to
do it so it's like let me do something I
don't want to do yeah that's that's how
I see it my thing is I so I like to do
it the first I literally I wake up go
downstairs and I just jump in my pool
and it's just like the first thing I do
is to start my day is something that's
not really fun yeah but like now I I
enjoy doing it because I feel great when
you get done with it but like you just
you accomplish something that really
sucks yeah and then the rest of your day
like yeah you can be dealing with other
stuff other issues but like you're doing
one thing that's difficult to do that
not a lot of people like to do and she's
like all right I'm gonna start my day
off by accomplishing something look
that's gangster yeah yeah I think that's
it man I think it's like yeah how can I
do something today that I don't want to
do it does make everything else a little
bit easier then
um it's even like going like going with
with going and working out like actually
I get a little bit excited because like
um I work out down there with Jeremy
holding those guys you know j-hole's at
my house today oh was he really yeah oh
dang that's my favorite oh he's
unbelievable but he's also like
he like dresses like he's trying to get
molested I feel like is that a crazy
thing he is a handsome dude 24 7 man he
smells like a barber shop too every time
but I think that I think is in the urban
community there's a lot better they they
tend to be a lot more fragrant yeah
you're not wrong Jeremy smells good all
the time I do I always try to we got
under her skin sometimes we always tell
him that he needs to brush his teeth
once in a while which he does but it's
just it's a fun way to talk [__] to
somebody because not really much you can
do if your breath smells like [__] oh
does his breath smell bad no it's just a
fun joke that we play on him because
there's not really much of a comeback to
that oh yeah that's true huh you had to
go brush your teeth yeah you're like
[__] you and you're like hey do I really
need my breath really bad that's what
people always do that's literally what
it is bro that is the best dude the the
worst thing is is when somebody does
have horrible breath and especially like
if they're at like a nightclub or
something and somebody's breath is bad
brutal oh and oh you know what a lot a
lot of times bro won't tell him dude
depends on if I like him or not I feel
you you got to be honest with like if
it's a buddy I'll definitely tell them
but if it's somebody so if you've got a
friend who has something in their teeth
you tell them
not if it's a girl so okay get this I
was at the Pro Bowl two years ago and
one of the reporters there I'd like I
was kind of going down the line you have
to talk to a certain amount of people
and uh I she probably interviewed like
six people before she got to me and she
just had a huge like piece of spinach in
her front two teeth and I was like you
were just on air with six people and no
one told you you have a camera guy with
four feet from your face I told her when
I started the interview I was like you
have some of your teeth I was like I
don't I would be so embarrassed if I
just said something my teeth the entire
time and no one told me like come on I
thought we were friends and women that
shakes them to the core oh it's almost
like telling them they don't even exist
I know that sounds crazy but you tell a
woman because it's like for some reason
it seems to be the only thing they care
about oh dude man they're always like
yeah
um speaking of women man your sister
taught me yoga yeah I know that's what
she was like yeah I'm teaching Theo Von
yoga and I was like really that's
awesome so cool man was that here yeah
yeah right here she taught me yoga
because I think you guys didn't live
very far away we literally have a block
away yeah I sold that we live out uh
like west of Nashville now but yeah we
lived there for two years yeah so it's a
pretty easy uh uh commute she's the best
man she was like very
she's like very like Mo like kind of
like ladylike and motherly but like very
like scent like a Sensei kind of she's
she she Vibes dude yes she's got a great
vibe to her yes like a Vibe Surfer or
something like you know she's like the
female layered Hamilton of Vibes I feel
like that's a Savage compliment man yeah
and she um dude she had me do this thing
one time it was like wearing these
things but between my toes right yeah
and it's like you Yoga Toes or I mean
it's just like this thing you wear at
night it's almost like a spacers yes or
what color were they blue or what uh
well I tried the freaking blue ones dude
the blue ones dude I'm obsessed with
those the blues I see you could probably
do but can you pull up those toe spacers
oh yeah dude I uh I got into those she
got me into those right so they're
awesome whenever I take my Netflix pet
the this Netflix special that I did
um she had been teaching right so if you
see me walk I'm walking out like this
because she taught me how to walk like a
Paleolithic yeah no I know exactly what
you're talking about dude we talking
about that stuff all the time right here
this kind of stuff oh yeah dude yeah the
those are the small ones they they have
a way bigger one uh they're massive and
blue oh the big one I felt like a [__]
with the bigger ones in they space you
out oh big gaps it was like God well now
is this a foot only fans account
is that where we're looking is this a
yeah I don't know
a lot of people make money off that man
that foot fetish will foot fetish was
the thing I think I'll help you
understand this because I don't
understand it I would guess if you are
I don't think it's a lot of American
money I think it's like a lot of Yen
that people spend on it those guys like
it because I think they're Japanese feet
are very little
dude you could eat probably a dozen of
them
and I you know what for context that
makes sense to me sure yeah
he's like going to Wingstop and getting
the 10 piece bone in or bone out man oh
I think if you're going Japanese feet
dude I'm keeping the bone in I want all
of it
I think I want the mayor I want all the
freaking you know the the gifts of the
Orient I feel like but I do think that
that is what it is they don't have very
long it's not like a precious like uh
thing over there it's almost like
you know it's so they don't get to see
it so I think for them seeing like a
long foot it's different with toenail
polish and stuff it's very Fantastical
to them my uh
Emma's uh fiance Cody he's a pitcher in
Japan and so he's like six five and he
says that the next closest person hardly
goes to his chest and so he just stands
out like a sore thumb and I was like
that's actually crazy so then you think
about feet like he's a size 14 to 15.
that's that's a lot for that's a lot out
there yeah he should we'll get the picks
up there for him and I think this yeah I
don't know if there's a market for it
for men
yeah what is going on with that foot why
do people have foot fetish can you look
it up please I'm gonna call into your
show and ask you that question
but you came here and asked it I know
but I'll just call in next time hey man
this is George I was there a couple
weeks ago you've solved this mystery yet
uh one researcher proposes that the
fetish is due to sensory input in the
brain the neuroscientist
villianur ramar chandran yeah suggests
that the part of the brain that
processes the sensation people get from
feet is next to the area that perceives
genital stimulation ah oh interesting
right arm so people want to see that
foot they want to see it gets them going
gets the blood going yeah I think you
know I have this exact same thing you do
yeah it's a nice one the Legacy flag guy
made it for you I think so yeah he hit
me up like four years ago and he made it
for me and I was like dude thanks yeah
it's hanging in my house it's in my barn
oh that's awesome I love it yeah we uh
he sent us this one and another one
we'll have to um we'll put his info up
actually right now he's done so much he
he's he does beautiful Flags so I'm
gonna make sure that we put it on the
screen there's nothing I could cool a
wooden American flag it's awesome like
Nick Bosa has I'm pretty sure that exact
same one in the back of his locker oh
wow it's awesome oh really in his locker
yeah just in the back of his locker I
think it got shipped there and he was
like this is cool and just set it back
oh that's crazy
um but yeah I guess that makes sense
about a foot because I think also if you
think back into Maybe
I wonder if like in old times you could
but if people were like cave people then
you saw the foot all the time you know
very true I'm just trying to think
they're really pretty back then though
were they no I'm sure kind of like
hobbit feet oh yeah I'm sure they were
very uh thick muscular I bet you they
were spread out though yeah very flat
huh flat wide toes I mean like because
you see the photos like indigenous
people and their feet they're literally
like they look like hands yeah oh my
gosh it's crazy and then I'm like
everyone's like that's the healthy way
that's what your feet want to look like
your shoes make your you know they close
your toe box in all that stuff well it's
kind of hard for me because my
profession I have to wear cleats that
are small and oh yeah you got to keep
them tight huh well to an extent like I
tried like I wear the toe space I try to
spread them out keep my feet as healthy
as I can but like once you get to
training camp in your I mean you're
taking like a couple hundred reps a day
it doesn't really help too much like
your feet Just Gotta Get You Gotta build
a callus to it basically is what you do
but then now I'm out at cleats right now
for a couple weeks it's like your feet
just lose that callus not to get back in
into it every single year it's wild your
feet kind of relax almost you can you
almost notice it and feel it oh yeah
like my feet feel significantly better a
month after the season than they do the
entire duration yeah it's wild yeah like
I don't this is a I've learned this
because I like pedicures it feels
fantastic I like getting my feet
massaged it's really nice getting them
cleaned up
um but like in the season I don't get a
pedicure for the entire season because I
don't want to lose any of the callus
like on the bottom of my feet I don't
want any of it scraped off because your
feet basically become these thick blocks
and you just gotta especially like where
I am I'm in the interior office I'm in
the office of line basically all the
time and so I get stepped on 24 7. so
like I like having tough feet but then
as soon as the season's over I'm back
getting pedicures and stuff it's
fantastic so you want to keep whatever
you can whatever a little extra you can
get yeah it's like I I hopefully my skin
is thicker about halfway through the
season dang it's wild do you all take
stuff that can make your skin thicker
I don't know like I mean like we have a
lot of supplements uh um our like our
team provides us and I'm just big I do a
ton I like collagen like that's my big
thing collagen and orange juice and then
any type of calcium I can get like those
are my two big things but that's a good
thing to look into why not I mean like
you see like my shins right here that's
just all cleats oh dang yeah like my
shins are just permanently cut up for
like my the rest of my life damn cleats
aren't really fun to get kicked by yeah
and do you get to wear shin pads or not
so the only guy that ever did that I'm
pretty sure is like Cam Newton did that
for a little bit I I contemplated doing
that but I like football is a really
weird sport where you just kind of get
lucky like I could be blocking somebody
and then the running back could miss me
by like an inch or he might kick me in
the calf when he's going past me and
she's like you just gotta get lucky
sometimes and right I got really lucky
this year where like yeah my shins were
getting beat up but like nothing else
and so I don't know if I want to be that
guy that's out there with the double
elbow pads double knee like you just
don't want to look like that and I just
I can't bring myself to wearing shin
pads yet yeah there's maybe an aesthetic
thing about it does it um are there but
their Cam Newton was the guy that did it
I think so I think that's what because I
brought it up and like one of my equip
managers told me that and I was like if
the only other person where shin guards
was a quarterback I just don't know if I
can do that to myself because oh yeah
because he kind of puts you on a
different level yeah I know I think I
just got to tough it out you know it's
it's for the the it's just for the sport
man it's Gotta tough it out yeah I could
respect that man I think sometimes yeah
you want to wear like I don't wear like
a turtleneck
you know I'm not a big turtle I don't
know if I've ever worn a turtleneck I
think there are guys that pulled off
really well that's just not my thing
you know who wears one Mike Ditka wears
a turtleneck a lot I see a large and I
think a lot of people that sell jewelry
wear it oh like a little fancy you might
see one like on a cool night in Miami a
lot of turtlenecks down there yeah maybe
I could see that kind of the Suave yeah
I think it's kind of like also like
Europeans or middle easterners wear it
now there's cam now that definitely
looks like diapers on the front of his
[__] yes those are those that's
basically what like basketball players
wear that's the type of shin guards so
like those aren't bad like I was
picturing wearing like the actual soccer
shin guards that are like the hard ones
I know who knows I might give it a shot
this year who knows if it doesn't affect
how I run which hopefully it doesn't but
you want to be as light as you can
because I mean the name of the game in
the NFL these days is speed yeah so
whoever's fastest is you know who makes
the most plays and who gets paid and
it's also I think
um it could be become a mental thing
like sometimes you feel like if you have
something on your body then it's way or
it's like 100 if it starts to become a
little bit of a hinge and it's not even
worth it I bet no that's 100 true
because like I had to get used I play
with the shoulders going on because was
it my second year I dislocated my
shoulder and so like to come back and
play and not miss any time I had like I
wore the shoulder sling and now I'm just
like uh superstitious about it and like
I saw like my shoulders are a little
messed up but like I don't need to wear
it but I literally just do it because
it's it helps me like just not totally
get out of the socket sometimes and but
for that that that took a lot of getting
used to just wearing something else in
my body because at first I was like oh I
can't lift my hand above my head and
then after all you just get used to it
and that's it that's the whole process
of it just getting used to it because
you know like uh the football like the
girdles that come with like the built-in
pads and like your thighs and your hips
and stuff like that it's like spandex
you'd wear yeah I've seen them yeah like
big panties yeah basically like they
have these thick pads in them and I wore
them in high school and then I didn't
wear them again until I tried them on
the NFL and it felt like I was wearing
like baggy pants and I hated it it was
just way too much going on and so I just
do like the little like those High
School white little pads you put into
your football pants because like it is
you just you don't want to wear a lot
because you're just trying to be as fast
as possible
you know one thing that was interesting
even when you're when your sister was
helping me do yoga and I just bring that
back because we would talk about you
sometimes and
um and she was always really interested
in like the next like staying on the
pulse of like
that is pretty cool huh that's awesome I
know dude it's always weird you think
like would you ever have like one of
those of yourself and then like somehow
you end up with one oh dude yeah I did a
bobble head thing like in 2018 or 2019
and I still have like 30 of them in a
box just in my in my barn just in
storage and then I got a Nickelodeon one
this year that's hilarious head is so
big let's bring it up I don't know if
you can find it but yeah it's hilarious
I gotta start get you know what I should
start doing for guests that we have on I
should start getting some bobbleheads
that's awesome have you seen uh you you
like the preds right hockey team um yeah
I like the prez they're not they don't
like themselves I don't think they're
not that good you know well so Phil
forsberg is like one of my best friends
I love that dude and uh I love going oh
yeah there it is look at that big head
oh my God that's you dude what were you
going through dude when I first opened
it I was like that boy's faded Theo that
boy right there is faded yeah dude look
whoa bro yeah hold on dude
she looks hot hey thank you
it's a nice yeah that from the back side
man that's aggressive oh
I just got slime thanks Nick really
appreciate it slime okay Nickelodeon man
oh now I get it I thought that was like
Between Two Ferns with Zach dude that'd
be awesome that's really what I thought
it was going on here
this looks like you I feel like in like
15 years
that's a faded old George right there
yeah huh that looks like George
um like if you were in uh like Pink
Floyd or like like if you were
definitely like riding in a small van
white van how many windows I mean some
of the windows had uh curtains because
you were also living in it I think I
think it has that kind of like we're oh
we're we're following the Grateful Dead
or we're following uh Widespread Panic
it's it's good it's I actually just got
my Fade to redone as far as coming from
a haircut oh you did I had to who does
your hair uh his name is Calvin he uh he
cuts a lot of the Titans players and so
I met him through uh one of the guys and
now he just cuts me on my buddy's hair
fantastic Izzy yeah North Nashville oh
wow yeah he really gets on there huh oh
yeah High bolt fade damn he's good at it
yeah I just got my hair cut today too
actually oh look at us that's crazy this
girl Whitney Cuts mine here in Nashville
um have you ever anyone mess up your
haircut like really bad oh dude one time
my freaking friend's dad first of all
never get your hair cut in
um
Mississippi
okay thank you just don't do it yeah
sure even if it's at the mall the casino
it doesn't matter
dude I got a haircut at a casino one
time bro dude I'll tell you what this is
crazy so yeah one time Chris Pratt
actually one time this is and I'm kind
of name-dropping but this is what
happened he sent me a DM he asked me to
be on a movie his right so I went
through all these things and got like
got the got the he helped me get the
part in the movie and then I got this
horrible haircut
and it made and we're just about to like
start taping and I also didn't uh I
didn't like the part was very small and
it was going to take like 12 weeks to do
oh yeah and I was like man this is just
it's a lot it's a lot and but what
capped it off was that day I had gotten
I'd had a show that weekend somewhere
and I got my hair cut in a casino in
Mississippi and it was so [__] bad it
pushed me over the edge I was like I
know I don't yeah I definitely want to
be on camera I don't want to be around
anyone I'm out yeah and this lady just
gotten out of like she went through like
this hair cutting rehabilitation program
through prison or whatever which I'm all
about let's look at your hair yeah good
for you man yeah that's what I was
thinking I was like God wants me here
this is what we're doing it was oh God I
wanted a [__] rope I should have gone
to prison on that on that lady it was
[__] bad dude and if I ever see that
[__] lady again somewhere you want to
go to casino Mississippi that was so bad
dude I was like I gamble I gambled with
my most valuable asset too that's tough
it is that's a good asset this is a
public service announcement
manscaped now has beard products
as well as a brand new nose and ear hair
trimmer
that's the worst you know one time I had
a buddy he shaved his head and he left
his ears just my God grew a dang Mitten
on each one of them
he just his ears were just dang ready
for winter
all year long
if you haven't already heard the leaders
and below the waist grooming are
traveling up north
with a revolutionary beard hedger Pro
kit yep
plus they've now launched the brand new
weed whacker 2.0
which that means they've they got your
whole body covered
do that Landscaping baby that manscaping
you know what I'm talking about
it all starts with the beard hedger this
thing is an elite beard trimmer it's
tough on hair but smooth on your face
ooh
leading a single stroke efficiency that
brings satisfaction one stroke at a time
now that you have your face looking
great you must try manscaped performance
package 4.0 for the full body grooming
experience
the performance package 4.0 now comes
with the weed whacker 2.0 and all the
other below the waist grooming products
manscaped is known for
you can get 20 off in free shipping with
our code Theo at manscaped.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use our code Theo always use the
right tools for the job with manscaped
you know I love the trimmers from there
in fact I just left mine at a hotel and
I'm gonna I'm gonna order one for myself
are you ready for UFC 286 the
welterweight champ will be decided in
the third matchup between Leon Edwards
and kamaru Usman
who will come out on top well
place your bets on DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
UFC right now new customers can bet just
five dollars to get two hundred dollars
in bonus bets instantly yup
plus all users can take the MMA action
to the next level with DraftKings same
game parlays download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app and use code t-h-e-o bet
five dollars on UFC 286
to get two hundred dollars in bonus bets
instantly that's code Theo only at
DraftKings Sportsbook 21 and up in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and state
specific responsible gambling resources
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler in
New York call
877-8-h-o-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y
which is four six seven three six nine
bonus issued as bonus bets terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com MMA terms
please gamble responsibly I'd wanna
so my hair got to a point where his soul
it was getting caught in my shoulder
pads and so I just went to a barber and
what I've realized now is that when you
have long hair you need to go to a salon
and like work with someone who knows how
to cut long hair yeah I just went to a
barber and I swear to God he gave me a
bowl cut without putting a bowl on my
head he'd let my hair down and he just
cut a circle around my head and I looked
at and I was like
it's tough for me it's really tough and
I had to go to a salon literally like an
hour later and they had to like fix it
for him but it was still brutal he just
went scissors in a circle it hurts huh
ah it really it was a struggle for me my
wife looked at me she was like what is
wrong with you I was like a lot of
things at this moment actually I gotta
leave yeah I've been neutered that's
what it feels like oh dude people don't
know once you've grown like like there's
something about like why I could see why
Native Americans would go and take the
scalp of a man because it was like the
most powerful [__] thing you could do
it's very disrespectful did you ever get
a haircut like uh during coven like did
anyone like I had a guy I had a
traveling Barber who I met through a
person through a personally like in
Nashville that's a homeless guy dude he
showed up and I asked him if her fade
and he cut it and then he was on the
back of my neck and he was talking to me
and he was a football fan so he's
talking and you know like when you know
somebody messes something up and they
try to hide it and like it was like this
and I was like he stopped for like two
seconds I was like you good he's like
yeah no nothing's wrong I go in and I
show my wife and he basically put a
lightning bolt as my neckline it was
absolutely brutal why did he do it he
was just not paying attention oh yeah he
was asking a football question and he
just got excited it was hilarious I
looked I was like you know what man just
thank you for the time yeah and I'm
gonna call it a day oh my goodness
there's nothing worse than getting a bad
haircut man it's brutal it just ruins
your whole day it may be a week oh yeah
it can ruin even more at least you're
married Bro dude think yes it helps a
lot God you have yeah you know a lady
still likes you when you [__] get
home yes imagine you get a shitty
haircut then you go home and it says
just staring in the mirror like oh my
God I can't leave the house you're
trying on different hats and [__] you're
like
you suddenly become a beanie guy you
know Theo why are you wearing a beanie
don't worry about it
you grow a beard that you can't even
grow it's just
[Music]
um but no one thing that I was
interested that was interesting about
and I keep going back to your sister but
I keep distracting you sir it's okay one
thing that was interesting was she's
like she helps train you guys do yoga
and stuff she's always like but she's
like yeah we stay on the try just try to
stay on The Cutting Edge she's just gone
to a conference I think about
I think it was some type of new yoga or
something I can't remember what it's
called but yeah but it was just
interesting she's like yeah our family's
big into this has your family always
been like because I got to meet your
father yeah and your mother at the gulf
uh at the Mother-in-law oh that's
mother-in-law yeah that's my mom's way
yeah is your mother still alive yes she
is she is she didn't go uh my dad yeah
you're good my dad I'm gonna remarried
no no no
oh your wife's mother my wife's mom yeah
my wife's mom she was in town for she
does she works with uh the NFL Hall of
Fame health and so like she works with
like former NFL players who are retired
who need help with medical stuff which
is it's really cool stuff but uh yeah I
brought my my sister my dad and my
mother-in-law cause my my sister my dad
they have the podcast now and so yeah
what's it called Us hidden pearls right
in Pearl's Pockets but they were there
in um Scottsdale for uh an event up
there and I just I happen to have a
couple extra tickets so they got to go
with me yeah it was cool man because
yeah I'd always heard about y'all's dad
and then
um and then it gets to see her sister
again was great but uh yeah has y'all's
family always been like
like super health conscious or like I
like my mom's been a vegetarian most of
my life oh wow and you grew up in the
midwest dude grew up in the midwest so
yeah god dude were people just throwing
like like Molotov cocktails no she was
fine she would like she eats fish once
in a while so like not true vegetarian
but like now I would say
uh I'd say like the last 10 years my
family's become like super health
conscious we're like my dad's 60 my
parents are both my dad's 64 my mom's
63. wow he looks great he does look
great but uh my dad like his side of the
family has like health issues and so
he's like I'm not gonna let that happen
to me and so I'm gonna be as healthy as
I possibly can so my dad's basically
vegan now for like the last five years
I'm gonna fight it bring him up with his
name is um Bruce Bruce Bruce Kittle
let's bring him up in here I want to get
a JPEG at his fella right here
because yeah he'd look at him there he
is oh yeah look at that guy and this
happened he's a little zinned out in
this picture but he's definitely a tough
man yeah he is
um
oh that's you and him that's me and him
is that right down the street no yeah
that was there oh that's crazy
um
so yeah so was he oh look at that hair
photo of him in college
where is it let me see oh wow I know
right so he took he went to the worst
Barber oh dude he tried to keep us there
for right he's been he's been bald since
probably like 40 45. he just shaves it
off so were you worried about that oh I
know that when I cut the hair I don't
know if it's going to come back very
well oh it is what it is so I'm just my
wife likes it so I'm gonna keep it as
long as she likes it and then I'll cut
it off when I cut it off and it is what
it is save it probably
we thought about cutting off some like
whenever I get my haircut saving it and
selling little 20 sacks of it at the uh
you could probably just walk down
Broadway people would buy it well we
want to sell it after comedy shows we
want to have a special thing where
there's like a limited edition 40 of
them and they're just little 20 bags and
like little drug baggies but not that I
know that's right that's like the dude
selling the sand from where Tom Brady
did his retirement speech from someone
sold it for 400 I was like are you like
who's gonna buy that why would you do
that so [__] sand monkey out there
um were you guys really tough because
you uh your your whole family's very fit
yes was that a big thing growing up was
there like like you get to like do chin
UPS to get seconds and stuff no not at
all no my uh my mom's a two sport Hall
of Fame athlete in Iowa high school oh
wow and softball and basketball uh my
dad was a football player and a wrestler
and so we just kind of been athletes
Emma was a great athlete she was like I
don't know like she's volleyball right
uh she played volleyball in college she
did basketball and volleyball in high
school I think she was like first two
him all state and all her stuff so she's
a freak athlete too so we've always just
been athletic but no like it wasn't uh
my dad was always big on like their dads
out there who are like very strict on
their kids about stuff my dad just gave
me like a template like hey these are
things that are going to lead to your
success you can choose to do them or not
I'm gonna help you like make the right
decision like I'm not gonna Force you do
it it's on you but like what are your
dreams I want to play in the NFL this is
going to help you get to there like just
doing these things a little bit better
but his biggest thing was like Hey work
hard try to get better and have fun
because if you have fun it's a lot
easier exactly my mindset interesting
yeah I just kind of Wonder yeah oh I
just wondered like yeah was it like real
Intense or was it not really it was you
guys having a good time yeah it was a
great time I mean yeah I mean there
wasn't too much strictness with it like
my parents are just they're always as I
mean I was a pretty good kid I didn't
really do a lot like I was very nice I
played football basketball and then I
came home and I played Halo 3. that's
about all I did oh dang it's pretty easy
I was low-key where are you yes very my
sister wasn't but you know you can have
her on the podcast discuss that yeah
maybe sometime that'd be interesting
um
so what else oh I was thinking about
this dude
um oh no there was one more question no
one had asked oh but y'all's family
seems really close very yeah we just
always have been it's just uh it's yeah
Mom Dad me and my sister so it's like we
moved around a bunch
um I went to like
I went to like 15 different schools
school districts basically growing up I
started in Wisconsin that's where I was
born moved back to Iowa because both my
parents their families are from there I
know my my mom is nine sisters so she's
one of ten girls wow and so oh I would
have loved to live next door dude
that's funny wow yes they lived in like
Small Town Iowa uh what town was it
Mount Union Iowa is what it's like Mount
Pleasant it's an hour south Iowa city
where the University of Iowa is okay so
it's just down Southeast Iowa so like we
moved back to Iowa then we just kind of
moved around a lot with my dad he just
want to be close to his job we had land
didn't like the house we lived in just
moved around a bunch interesting yeah my
mom went to college now I think at like
Colin colleges
yeah I've had friends that go to coat
College yeah that's cigarette was an
interesting Town yeah it's interesting
oh I like Dubuque maybe a little bit
more that's where my wife's from really
yeah yeah on the border I like dubuqueas
they got some really neat hotels and
stuff right there along the river oh
yeah what is that called did you stay in
the room where
Al Capone's in it right yeah that's
right I was in that room too were you
the Juliet or something like that yeah
Julian Hotel it's Dubuque Dubuque Iowa
like to Julius or Juliet something like
that yeah that's a it's a cool hotel and
one of my buddies got married there oh
wow yeah it's beautiful yeah Mark Twain
I think would write a lot about that
area and stuff it was really well it's
right on the dubuque's around the corner
so like you cross a bridge into Illinois
or Wisconsin and so it's kind of a cool
area I didn't know that yeah there's
just big bridges that go across go tell
Julian maybe Julian yeah that's it
that's it I was close I got the jewel
right and it's haunted it says read it
read it about Al Capone he's booking us
a damn room dude come on man we're just
friends yeah no like it there was a room
that he stayed in that he put like
um I don't know if it was a safe or like
a closet it was a hidden door that you
would hide in if like cops ever came to
the hotel
and so they just leave it permanently
open now
yeah I was right there we go there you
go Hotel Julian Dubuque became known as
one of the finest hotels in the Midwest
and hosted many Grand Banquets and
famous guests but all the personages
said to have stayed at the hotel local
lore alleges that when things got hot in
Chicago Capone would travel with his
Entourage to Dubuque and hide out at
hotel Julian yeah there's like a hidden
room and there's a hidden room in that
hotel room and they leave it open like I
said out but it used to like blend in oh
wow it was really cool stuff that's cool
yeah yeah I really like Dubuque though I
just even just walking around the little
the the downtown I really enjoyed it
um
dude you have like this do you start to
feel like um
you have like this almost like like
wrestling type of vibe about you right
and people have said that you're a
wrestling fan do you start to do you
like
do you feel like more of a character
when you're playing football sometimes
these days
um maybe I think football is a place for
like I authentically get a I mean I
think I'm authentically myself all the
time but the great thing about football
is it's one of the only professions
where you get to beat the [__] out of
someone not get arrested for it yeah
there's not very many of those sports
right yeah and so that's really fun for
me and like except Memphis maybe I think
he can do it these days but yeah I don't
think it's like as sanctioned yeah
probably not you know it's frowned upon
yeah yeah frown upon but like in the NFL
so like I just get to go out there and I
get to hit people I gotta have fun I
mean I'm playing a kids game dude and
getting paid a lot of money to do it so
like I'm gonna work my tail off but I'm
gonna enjoy it every second that I'm out
there because you only get so many reps
there's only so much tread on the tire
and you got Tom Brady who can play for
20 years maybe 21 and then like you know
but the average you know lifespan is
like three years so I'm going to near
seven I'm doing pretty well for myself
so it's like hey I'm gonna play as long
as I can I'm gonna play at a high level
as long as I can but I'm gonna have a
great time every time I'm out there and
do you feel like it's a uh it's easier
for guys now is there more of a like the
aspect of it now where
let me think of exactly what I'm trying
to say so
it seems like you want to stay in it
longer now right everybody's always
wanted to stay in it longer but now it's
obviously a it's a it's a bigger
business now than it was 20 years ago oh
yeah I mean there's significantly more
money in it I mean you just saw like two
quarterbacks just got paid over 100
million dollars with like 70 million
dollars one guy got guaranteed like 83
million dollars that's more than my
entire contract wow that's wild that's
why it was Daniel Jones right yeah good
for him happy for him I love it when
guys the NFL get paid because it's
really hard to get paid wow and so once
like I love everybody getting paid I do
not care who they is if I think they're
a good player if I think they're a bad
player awesome you got paid good you're
set for life like just don't squander it
please what do you mean when you say
it's hard for guys to get paid well like
you have to the NFL is full of like
every NFL player College you have high
school which is like you have hundreds
of thousands of kids playing High School
right and you just think about like the
number you have millions of kids playing
High School you have hundreds of
thousands of people playing uh college
football there's 1500 NFL players like
just like the percentages is so small
then when you get there like every team
has all Americans in college Heisman
Trophy winners and just like you have to
figure out what you do better than
everybody else and how to do like how to
do that for as long as you can and
that's kind of what the NFL is like
surviving NFL is really hard like
there's fantastic players and athletes
out there that should be NFL and aren't
right like that happens all the time
it's like a lot of guys don't take
advantage of that opportunity so it's
hard to get paid you have to have the
right you have to take advantage of that
opportunity what's in front of you are
there any players that come to mind when
you're like man that player it just it
didn't pay it out or they got air there
was a injury that happened or I mean
like uh one of my let's see one of my
favorite football players of all time
was Bob Sanders he's a safety for the
Indianapolis Colts he played for Iowa uh
he won defensive MVP one year but like
he just had an assortment of injuries
and he would have been in my he was the
first ballot Hall of Famer and then he
just had all these injuries that he
couldn't stay healthy and then he played
in the pros oh yeah here's what the NFL
MVP for defense like amazing football
players a safety which is really hard to
do these days and he was incredible and
uh yeah he had like a back injury had
leg injury shoulder injuries because he
hit people so hard and maybe he'd be
hurt and it's just like instead of being
a first Hall of Famer like he'll always
be remembered as a really good football
player but like injury kind of took that
away from him and so he could have
gotten paid a lot more money too
probably uh that's what's hard it's like
you have to stay healthy you have to be
in the right situation you have to make
a lot of plays and you have to get into
those like what are the years you kind
of get paid on what are some of those
levels it's like uh after the most of
the time is like I got paid after year
three okay for your rookie deal most of
the extensions happen after three years
or you can after your four-year free
agent is what you're seeing now like
that's where the real money is because
like everyone's bidding on you and
that's where the good stuff is
um but yeah most guys get paid after
three if you're a first-run draft pick
like teams have a fifth year right to
you and so those first round draft pick
Matt and I get paid till after year four
um but they already got a you know first
John signing bonus so like they're doing
well for themselves I see do you think
it like as a player gets into that year
where it's like okay the next year
they're gonna get paid is it common
where guys will kind of and maybe this
is an overall question I was trying to
ask earlier where
you'll do you feel like oh as overall as
the league that the players everybody's
almost like all right let's don't go too
crazy here today so that we can all play
again next year there is a I would say a
majority of the NFL like a high majority
NFL is not trying to hurt other players
I give a couple crazy guys that don't
care if they do like I don't think their
intention is I'm trying to blow your
knee out I don't think that's a thing
really anymore but I definitely like
there are there are some guys who are
more conscious about it than other guys
and like there's hits that you can't
avoid and it is what it is but um yeah I
think I was like I've had a time this is
my third year it was like week 15 and
I've been healthy the entire year and
I'm Larry um there's a pile right behind
me and a guy and like my legs are pinned
and if a guy wanted to he could like
literally just throw me backwards it's
gonna be a really awkward fall for me
instead of like he grabbed me and pulled
me out of the way and he's like dog
you're worth too much to do that I was
like I really appreciate you thank you
so much it's very nice of you you're
amazing and so like I happened to me and
I was like you know like that's kind of
high into like I never want to hurt
anybody like I cut block you know I have
to like how do you expect yeah I'll do
it at the [__] mall
dude's ankles put your head through his
kneecap you do it like and there's like
there that's football right like and
people want to Outlaw certain things
like I like the try not to hit him in
the head like I appreciate that like I
don't want to get in the head a lot it
sucks
um concussions aren't fun but um yeah
just getting ahead and hitting the head
but in general like just kind of sucks
so like guys are conscious about that I
like the protection NFLs but like
there's certain jobs like there's
certain jobs like hey I'm gonna cut
block you and I'm Gonna Hate in the
knees and you know I I don't like try to
hurt anybody through it but like just
it's a part of the game yeah so it's
kind of weird but like I said it's
violence that's
um appreciated by everybody yeah I think
that's true so you have to does it
almost start to feel like wrestling then
at some point late in the league like or
like to an extent like there's there's a
lot like there's yeah I would say to an
extent like I would say there's a
handful of us out there who are treating
like wrestling too and like you know
having fun out there like that but uh
yeah I mean everyone's just everyone's
out there everyone wants like everyone's
goal is to win a Super I mean I hope
everyone's goals to win a Super Bowl
like that's what my goal is and then
whatever comes with that but like I'm
not gonna go out of my head like you
know because it's like too much pain on
somebody but enough right
right yeah because I think yeah I wonder
if it used to be different you know I
think back in the day they cared less
about each other
but there's a lot more going on back
then like a lot of dude did you ever see
the clip of it was on Instagram but it
was like the 1980 maybe like 1990
highlight for like MB or CBS like uh
Sunday football or something like that
and like the whole highlight video is
just like guys getting their knees taken
out guys getting thrown onto their heads
like just getting smoked and like oh
every every highlight in that like cut
up is illegal in today's game wow which
is crazy but guys used to get messed up
back in the day but then you have to
take in like are the guys that played in
the if you played in the NFL you're a
fan like good for you you were a good
athlete like you played at a high level
you played it with the best but like the
game in the 80s and even the 90s is way
different than it is today like just the
athletes too like you got guys out there
running four 240s like left and right in
the 80s you might have had one guy in
the whole NFL that could do that but now
it's like every team has three guys it's
just crazy how the game's evolved and
now like look at like you guys see guys
like miles Garrett that dude six five
280 pounds and he's just muscle with
five percent body fat it's just like
like
he didn't ex they didn't exist right he
didn't he didn't exist 20 years ago
that's crazy they didn't even exist yeah
like he just didn't like that wasn't a
thing or like you might add one in the
entire NFL but like now the like guys
that look like that are everywhere I
have like five guys in my locker room
that if they wanted to if they punch me
in the face I could die
it's wild like I'm just like oh my like
his fist is the size of my entire face
and he could kill me with one punch it's
kind of weird to go to work with people
like that yeah I bet it's weird oh I
would keep a little treat bag on me like
they do with like what they're raising
uh you know somebody that's raising some
Skittles yeah or just something
no I'd give him a probably a decent meat
or something I give a damn wag go at
that level you gotta keep them please
yeah hey where would you want a bottle
of tequila wine what do you want you
want canis yeah Hey Ron calm down on
this next play a little bit hey dude uh
thank you yeah
um that's funny you were talking about
having a I I read something summer you
were you were thinking that they should
have an extra bye week right oh I'd love
to talk about this Theo yeah so we we
the NFL it starts in I see I leave for
training camp July 24th okay and what is
it now January February it's like March
but so you report in July 24th and my
season technically ended on January 29th
that's a long season
right okay so you have five months off
ish but like we have Spring football
that starts April 15th and that's two
months oh dang what do you have to do
there uh it's not it's not as much
contact but you're just the first like
two weeks is just working out like
getting you into shape and you have to
be there uh basically you can zoom no so
uh it's it's not mandatory one of those
things like they want you there
um some guys have workout bonuses in
their contracts so they can only miss so
many days but like their coaches want
you to be there if you're a vet like
there's gonna like Trent Williams
probably won't show up you know for a
couple weeks because like he doesn't
really need to get better at football
not gonna lie like he's probably the
best football player in the NFL okay as
our office of lineman our left tackle
but like there's certain guys that don't
do OTAs
um but it's really beneficial for young
guys because you just learn the Playbook
you go to the meeting it's kind of like
uh if you haven't really been in NFL too
much it's kind of like a just it's a
boot camp for the season yeah just kind
of gets you ready for it and like
there's a there's one week that's
mandatory at the end of it that
everybody has to go to or you can signed
but it's not mandatory I always go to
like like the I usually show up like May
1st I'm like two weeks late usually just
because my like I didn't get yesterday
was my first day in Nashville wow really
and it's like yeah the first week of
March and so like the entire month of
February I was doing stuff whether it
was Pro Bowl I was at the Super Bowl
doing some like gigs
um working with some of my marketing
partners and then after that I did like
a 10-day vacation with my wife because I
was like I haven't gone on vacation in
seven months so I'd like to go see a
beach yeah sounds really nice right now
so Maui I went so I did Maui last year
Hawaii is awesome beautiful so great it
is beautiful I wish it wasn't as
expensive as it is but like I get it but
like I don't know like there's a
beautiful place in the world that I
haven't been but that's one of my
favorite places like you're in the ocean
and there's just massive islands that
look like they could move at any second
no and wreak havoc like that's how I see
I'm like wow that's some cool stuff but
I was I wasn't living like damn breath
of the wild you're living like Zelda
style dude that's what it feels like
dude yeah you're thinking like that
I'm like that is that like a giant
Pokemon is that gonna stand up and come
over here dude like that stuff Freaks
Like that's what I think about when I'm
out there I'm like wow I'm just chilling
right now I know right I'm a 13 year old
kid Theo yeah it seems like that it
seems like you're just kind of like
living in these crazy adult like dream
worlds of a child but that you're
actually getting to navigate through
them
um
so so what about that extra bye week so
you oh yeah sorry yeah bye week no it's
okay season like January let's say July
24th right and you're like fully
practicing let's just say July like the
first couple days are pretty easy but
like by August 1st you're going full
speed go from August 1st until if you're
in the playoffs or like uh Super Bowl
like it's mid-February your body's just
rolling and getting beat up and so and
then LA with two years ago they added a
17 a 17th game yeah who did that the
money people you know what ah I voted no
on it but it is what it is it just you
guys vote count uh well so there is well
um like it was a new CBA uh the
bargaining agreement and they put in
how I understand it and I was explaining
to me is like they kind of just put the
17th game out there and as players are
bored or like the player voted reps
we're like no we're not going to do that
and then when they finally gave us an
offer it was kind of like you're gonna
accept this or else and it somehow
passed the voting process and then went
to the players and it wasn't
um
I don't know how well it was explained
because it was in the middle of covet
too so it's really hard to get a hold of
people like it was weird and like that
was like zoom zoom was just kind of
getting along too so like it was
difficult to you know get a lot of
people on a phone call I'm thinking
about these 1500 guys in the league they
were trying to do T like League wide
meetings can you imagine 1500 people on
a phone call yeah like it it was crazy
and so like it was difficult to get all
the information out there so we voted
and what I however many people voted
like there's a possible of like 1500
votes only like 800 people voted out of
the 1500 or something like that and the
thing it passed and so the 17th game was
included now and so they added a 17th
game and so this is all my theory is if
you're gonna add a game so the week The
Season's 18 weeks long because there's
one bye week for every team right if you
just add another bye week and you give
everybody two it'll be a 19-week season
there's more there's more weeks of
football more money to be made and your
best players are staying healthy so like
why not just do it it makes simple sense
to me because and you can just I don't
like any player right now if the NFL
announced like we're gonna give
everybody a second by a week I don't
think anybody would ever complain about
that and like okay that makes our season
one week longer now we're getting done
the third week of February okay like
maybe take out a week of OTAs and just
give us a week on the back end you know
let guys you know go on vacation or give
another guys a week to train it's like
once you're in the NFL and it's your job
like everybody wants to play football it
doesn't really take me a lot to get
motivated to play football I love what I
do and I think everybody else does so
it's like and there's like young guys
you have to keep them like in line kind
of because they don't understand it yet
like OTS and stuff like that but if you
get like there's NFL guys want to show
up and they're going to play at a high
level because they want to get paid they
love playing on the football field you
feel like a gladiator when you stand in
the new Raider Stadium and it's straight
up and there's whatever 70 000 people
looking down on me oh dude it's one of
the coolest feelings ever like you
literally look up kill somebody at
halftime you feel like it dude it's
really fun so my whole thing is just
like add a bye week I don't think
anyone's gonna get upset about it and
your best player is going to stay
healthier longer you know I'm a big fan
of Raising Canes baby you know that God
I could eat it every day
I mean I just I wish to rate days in a
week so I could eat it eight times a
week that's how much I want it
and that secret sauce whoo like it just
Whispers right into my dang taste buds
you know that that buttery Texas toast
the crinkle cut fries come on come on
and they do it and they do it right you
know my go-to-order is that Caniac combo
and I don't know if you know it but it's
easy to order on their mobile app or
online at raisingcanes.com that's right
satisfy your canes fixed fast by
ordering through their app or online at
raising canes.com or stop by your local
restaurant hmm I want my cane raised
baby did you know that shipping costs
are the number one cause of abandoned
carts online did you know it well now
you do
have you ever left a cart full of items
in an online store because the shipping
was too expensive
well if you're selling stuff online you
can prevent that and keep your customers
happy when you use ship station
you can lower shipping costs you can
make returns easy and again you can keep
those customers content
ship station effortlessly integrates
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon Shopify eBay Etsy and more
manage every order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print labels easily compare rates
and delivery times and automate delivery
notifications you can do it all
get up to 88 off USPS and UPS rates and
if that's not enough use my promo code
to try ship station free for two months
you want to make sure your customers get
to shipping and that doesn't send them
away
use promo code Theo today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's a lot of time
to check it out that's shipstation.com
promo code Theo get a 60-day free trial
at shipstation.com
slash t-h-e-o thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring the show it does make sense
how tough is it to stay how tough is
that turnaround on the body honestly is
it really tough like Sunny to Sunday
yeah on that Sunday to Sunday I like I
don't I don't get that it's hard to
understand yeah no it's literally I'm in
a car accident every Sunday multiple car
accidents every Sunday like multiple
every Sunday and like like I said
earlier like there's a part of luck to
it like like there's a game like I've
had games where I hyper extend my knee
and like that's gonna that's gonna
affect your season like that's gonna be
there or you burst a bursa sack in your
knee that's going to be there for
several weeks and if you get luck you
don't have to deal with that stuff it's
a little bit better but like you're
still getting these car accidents and
like Monday you actually like Monday I
have to do like a big lower body lift I
have to move otherwise you get really
stiff and like you get more sore so you
do a big lift try to stay a little bit
mobile but Mondays I usually feel okay
Tuesdays are really really hard days
like it's like the second day afterwards
you kind of feel everything Whiplash
kind of yeah it's literally what it is
and like there and there's some Tuesdays
are better than others like some like
and especially like if we play on the
East Coast we have a five hour flight
back I get home at four a.m those are
tough but um like you get in these car
accidents and like it takes like
Thursday to Fridays when I start to feel
like myself again
and it's and then like the longer end of
this the more you end of the season you
get the more like your body to wear and
tear wear and tear wear and tears are
like really now like how I see it is as
if if I'm not doing football I'm doing
recovery whether it's tubs whether it's
bfr workouts whether it's just movement
yoga
um red light therapy saunas like
whatever it is that can make my body
hyperbaric chambers are big now
um whatever is like available I that's
all I do like I get home from practice I
get home at like let's just say on a
Wednesday I'll be home at like 6 6 30.
I'm instantly my next two and a half
hours are rehab and and like you can do
a lot of stuff at the stadium what I've
done is be
um because I got I got a contract so I
like I can afford to have a lot of that
stuff in my house now so then I get home
fast I can hang out with my wife for
longer because like my first two years
and my first three years in the league I
was at the facility for Mike
are they our meeting started let's say
for me to start at eight I'm there from
6 15 until like 7 30 8 o'clock at night
for like yeah it's just it's a long day
especially and then like I want to be
home I want to be with my wife
um and so it's just like I've purchased
those things I have in my house and so I
just I have a couple extra hours but
like Larry that's all you do now is
rehabbing Rehabilitation and there are
guys that don't do that I don't know how
they survive I don't understand it yeah
it's it's actually crazy like some guys
like they don't have to do all that
stuff but that's something I'd like I've
dedicated my well I mean like the
football window is like I said the
average lifespan's three years so I mean
like the window in the grand scheme of
my life uh my college my rookie sorry my
freshman year at a coach uh David Wright
told me this he was like I drew on a
board it's like if you line here and lie
here let's just say it's 100 years right
that's your life I'll do it so you can
see it 100 years this is zero
and like so here you are you're 18 years
old you're right here this four-year
window of college is this big
and then you have the rest of your life
why not take advantage of that small ass
window right do everything you can to be
the best you can do this for years so
now after college now you get a chance
in the NFL and now you're getting to the
now it's this big it's a bigger window
but it's still like a sliver it's like
12 to 12 years of your life yeah one
tenth of your life and so like why not
put all your effort into being available
and being the best player you could
possibly be yeah and like like there are
guys like I don't touch I don't ski I
don't do anything possible like I don't
even play pick up basketball anymore
like I'm just like it's not what you
hide and go seek you think I could do
that yeah yeah freeze tag maybe I was a
big freeze tag guy back in the day
really do you ever play Ghost in the
graveyard
like you have one per you play at night
and like one person and like you have to
hide and the whole point of the game is
if they tag you you're a ghost you have
to make it back to the home base which
is where the ghost Counts from and they
give you like like they go around the
clock one time and then it strikes
midnight and then the ghost comes for
you oh damn I used to play the hell out
of that game it was so fun really I
never got tagged really yeah ghost in
the graveyard it's so much fun damn
that's like that's what I played when I
was like four five six like that was
that was some of my favorite playing we
didn't play I don't think we played that
I don't know they had so many pedophiles
in our neighborhood we didn't even try I
shouldn't you shouldn't hide yeah
dude Well yeah if you do get found as
possible man who has cable or whatever
use cable there's some [__] he's
gonna kick up yeah it's always just some
[__] lie or something you know I got
two VCRs you know like we can watch
movies you can just look at the other
one you know just some bait we have two
movies on at the same time they're just
[__] to blow a kid's mind you know
um that's funny were we just talking
about right before that though
um
like the window of your career and stuff
well if it even happens with comedy it's
like I know it's like I know when I get
back off the like when I'm on the road
it's like I know that I have to do yoga
right before I go on stage right yeah
I'll finish yoga literally probably
about nine minutes before I go on and
then I'll get in the shower I'll take
like a three minute shower okay and then
I'll get out and it's just that's my
pattern right it's like if I'm up late
I'll make sure that I get eight hours of
sleep yeah um which so let me ask you
this so so like football on our game day
right Sundays depending on whenever you
like you kick off at 1 35 125 whatever
it is the schedule is perfectly adjusted
for they they'll tell you when you
should wake up and like breakfast is
here the bus leaves at this exact time
and it's you know in accordance like but
it's always the exact like it's two now
it's three hours before kickoff it's two
and a half hours before kickoff and
everything is regimented perfectly so
like I have the every Sunday I do the
exact same thing
I mean I usually I'm very I like my
routines like yeah to get into the
mindset and flip the switch to like go
out there and play football and so like
from about yeah I mean from Saturday
morning until after the game Sunday like
I do the exact same thing every time
yeah it's wild but like so like you were
saying like you do yoga and you go
shower that habit yeah it's kind of
interesting to hear like how yours is
different than mine but you still have
something like that before you go on
stage yeah and when I get home it's like
I'll have to like I make sure I go to
the make sure I go to the work out with
the trainer guys whenever I'm home right
I make sure I go get the NAD and like uh
I'll get the NAD and the uh extra fluids
probably I'll probably go every other
day do you yeah and if I don't get an ad
every time I'll get at least the extra
fluid every time just to keep myself
hydrated I go to arati yeah yeah or yeah
they keep changing the name of it but
they
um but yes nice in there the women in
there is good with the needle in there
they're they're they know what they're
doing you ever have a bad like IV
experience dude
my buddy the other day we [__] I'm
backstage he's like yeah I'll get an IV
too I'm like yeah give it a boy right
bro this [__] lady put like [__]
nine holes
and he's like six three of me he can't
find a [__] Vein on this guy dude
that that gives me anxiety I don't I'm
not a big needle guy by any means I had
my first IV I ever got was because I had
to get uh I had to get ankle surgery in
college and uh the first time she missed
my veins six times oh my God and then
she got and then she called someone else
in to do it and they did it and I was
fine a month later I had to go back and
do the other ankle and um the lady got
on her first try there wasn't a lid on
it and my blood just started skirting
out and I just passed out those are my
first two experiences with IVs and so
I'm kind of shook with them but I do it
like and you need the liquid you need
the hydration like the benefits that
they have outweigh my mild
uncomfortableness
yeah I think that's it and I start to
get over it I will what I'll do is when
I'm to make them do one two three before
they put the needle in and then I'll
like jab my fingers into the side of my
head to give an opposite pain yeah so
pain transfer Theory yeah yeah I bite
the [__] on my tongue it helps dude I
just bite my tongue I haven't done that
it sucks
or by your lip either one I'm not doing
that's crazy I feel like it is
psychopathic sometimes
next time I see people they just have
you eat your whole lip off oh no I bite
the hell out of my tongue if I'm doing
something uncomfortable oh that's
interesting yeah but I'll do that I'll
like yeah I'm sure the women in there
what is wrong with him they must think
men are just the whip because they're
like having to give birth or whatever
like Pierce their breasts or whatever
but like man men are like you know we
can't even take the take that needle
from them
um but I do think the nad's interesting
I noticed with the NAD I'm able to just
go from one like this exercise this
exercise keep going it's almost like I'm
not even in my body it's like I'm just
keep doing it you're not like I I I
don't do it all the time
um I do I do like it though like I think
I I was just I wake up with more energy
like that's the thing I just that's what
I'll always do it like in the afternoon
and it kind of makes me sleepy like I'm
not gonna lie but like the next day I
feel fantastic and that's kind of how I
view it and I don't do it all the time I
know some guys that like do a thousand
milliliters I'm like you guys are
psychopaths like I was doing I got up to
like 500 and I was doing about 22
minutes I was pretty proud of myself
damn that's insane that was like that
was a couple years ago like now dude I
can already do a hundred I'm just like
oh this is the worst experience of my
life it just burns you down you guys
were doing it five years ago no sorry
like
no I was dude I was doing 500
milliliters like two to three years ago
okay that's when I kind of got in wow
that's still a long time ago I feel like
it's just kind of become popular amongst
us like I just I'm just a pretty much a
regular person so I would hear about
like more knowledgeable like people are
just under maybe thousand months ago
yeah yeah I think it just gets promoted
a little bit better like the benefits of
it like there's are things out there
that well one for athletes it's legal
and it's healthy for you so it's just
like well why would I not do something
that's gonna help my body and just feel
better overall it is expensive though oh
my gosh it's a dollar a milliliter it's
crazy easy dude it's crazy it's like
printer ink yeah dude yeah why is that
so expensive that's crazy dude it is
crazy they Jack it up I guess if you
want to read you're gonna [__] pay
for it you [__]
but um so if you got into wrestling dude
say after this because that's what I I
think I could you start to become
some some guys they become some players
are some some athletes they are also
able to become like a character in a way
I feel like you have like the enough
energy and like
just like this kind of psycho Charisma I
would call it where you can also be like
a character yeah and it's like I do mean
it as a compliment but it's like so I
could almost see you doing wrestling one
day I would love to be in the ring at
some point really yeah it's so like I've
been I was in a match uh it was actually
right after I got drafted by the Niners
my buddy was doing a
um like a local it was like an hour away
from my for my house in Iowa he was
doing a show and it's actually uh Seth
Rollins WWE wrestler it's his wrestling
school in Davenport Iowa and they put on
shows and so he was in Quad Cities yeah
Quad City oh yeah yeah look at this guy
I love the Midwest I've been a Field of
Dreams man I've been to where the plane
crashed where uh Ritchie Valens died in
the Big Bopper I love that yeah I can't
remember the town name but anyway good
for you the Midwest is awesome it's just
different yeah it's a lot different than
California it's a lot different than
here I like it dude I like some
grandmother [__] forcing some cookies
in you you're gonna you're gonna eat and
you're gonna like it
dude I [__] love that your bike tire
would just get all Caked Up in it oh
that's hilarious I'd love that [__] what
were you talking about
um we're talking about you doing
wrestling so first of all you went to
Seth Rollins you had a school in Dallas
thank you so they put on a show and I
got in the ring right after I got
drafted and I did I got to pull a stone
cold stunner on somebody that was
exhilarating
um they were like I want to say there's
between
40 to 60 people in this little Arena I
mean and it was like it was like um
lives like just it was a building that
had didn't have uh like seating in it so
it's like just an open space like a Rec
Center sorry okay yeah rec center and
there's literally like 40 people in
there maybe and the pop everybody's
standing up and cheering like that was
one of the most exhilarating feelings
I've ever had in my life so like
literally from that moment I was like I
get why people wrestle it is
exhilarating when you get the crowd to
go oh my gosh
literally it's so much fun and so yeah
like I I can't wait till I have the
opportunity to get thrown through a
table or throw someone through a table I
can't wait
it's gonna be amazing it'd be really
really interesting do you think who who
from the NFL would if you had to do tag
teaming if you had to have a tag team
partner from the NFL who would you pull
in now like
from like an athlete's standpoint like
just football player I'd pick Trent
Williams because he could he's one of
the yeah he's incredible bring him up
and see if he can get him topless or
whatever just because we want to see
what who he is look up Trent Williams
back tattoo his nickname's the
Silverback oh really he's literally a
gorilla oh dang he yeah he's one of the
guy one of the Five Guys on my team that
could kill me with a punch
wow oh yeah there it is that's yeah I
mean he's he's like fully tatted now up
top
oh that's him he's big huh yeah that's
young Trent Williams right there
but he's a stud but I would pick him now
if I was gonna pick someone who I think
would do like be a good WWE character
like it'd be a really good WWE wrestler
um
I think I mean Travis Kelsey like we'd
have a pretty fun uh like Titan Titan
Duo right there yeah the tightest ends
up could be called
um ends that are tight
I don't know Titus I mean I think you'll
get a new type of fan in the arena
you're not wrong I mean and that's fine
what is that fan you I mean no sir oh
okay I love women's but I think that
there is a there's I think yeah you
could get a whole my current profession
I play in Tights is it is so that's a
good point huh yeah I'm used to it but
no like there are some great characters
in the NFL who I think could make easy
transitions over I mean you saw Gronk
did it like he was at WrestleMania
several years ago but did he won it
though Gronk I feel like gets he he like
he he gets put in all like everything
you know he's selling shave lotion he's
selling damn Parkers or whatever I saw
him on a um somebody had him in a uh
somebody was doing Animals selling
puppies or whatever rescue animals or
something so I think you know he's
almost done so many things he does do a
lot and I was like did he want it though
like I could see you maybe becoming a
member in it do you feel like you would
just do it as a fun thing or do you feel
like it could be something you would
actually
I think I would have really enjoyed
doing that right now like I will say
like after meetings like I've got the
awesome Mark too WWE is a fantastic
company like how they organize and run
their stuff like I've got I've gotten
able to go I've been able to go like
three wrestlemanias oh wow and this
literally this last one like the way
that it's ran picked us up picked me and
my dad and one of my buddies up and my
wife we gotta go backstage I gotta hang
out with Undertaker Stone Cold Steve
Austin I got to meet all these like
people that I'm a huge fan and then also
wrestlers are like when they're behind
the scenes like they're just they're
normal like I'm an NFL football player
and people see me like oh my gosh some
like some like kids are like oh my gosh
it's George kidding like that's how I
was a kid like NFL players are kind of
superheroes that's how kind of I am with
wrestlers I'm like it's so cool but as
soon as you get them off the stage
they're just normal people like the rest
of us so just like just have a
conversation with them they're all so
cool like multiple guys are just hanging
out with my dad talking about random
stuff and like being able to have that
access is so much fun and so like that's
part of the reason that makes me really
want to you know try it and I think I
would enjoy it but I'm sorry I was gonna
say is like their schedule like they're
on the road
320 40 days they don't get enough credit
for their schedule oh my gosh like if
they're doing the Because you see
everyone you see Monday Night Raw you
see I think AWS on Wednesdays and then
you have Friday Night Smackdown and then
you have if there's a pay-per-view it's
on Saturdays or Sundays and then you
don't even count the ones that aren't on
TV there's like two uh non non-televised
shows um a week yeah there's like 80
there's a couple of other ones but like
no WWE puts them on they'll do like I
think they'll just they'll go like the
Dubuque Iowa and it won't be on TV but
it'll be in that air whatever Arena
that's selling tickets and they're just
selling tickets to put on the show so
it's for local shows and so it's a much
smaller production than like the live TV
ones but I've gone to a couple of those
and they're still really fun but it's
just like this they're they're in the
ring like I perform once a week they're
in the ring and we're at yes there's a
script to it but like you can't fake
falling off like getting thrown through
a table you can't fake jumping off the
top rope to the ground which is a 10
foot yeah it's like even if you went to
Phantom of the Opera but what if people
are beating the [__] out of each other
during it yeah like come on like it's
gonna hurt
so like that's why I decided I have
appreciation for wrestlers because it is
a grind one of my buddies like he's been
doing it since like he stopped playing
football with it so like let's just say
six years he has driven like he lives in
Davenport Iowa and he's driven probably
I mean he goes to Maryland to wrestle
Florida to wrestle California to wrestle
Arizona to wrestle Nashville like he and
he just drives he doesn't fly that's
another thing they make him drive George
they get into a lot of these guys they
get they land they go to Avis they go to
the rental it is a you have to it is a
grind it is on you it is yes it's on you
to show up and be available to wrestle
like then you have like and like the
superstars in WWE like they probably
they fly and they do stuff but like a
lot of people literally just drive match
the match week the week year to year and
not even the superstars like I'm friends
with The Miz who's a wrestler yeah oh
The Miz is great man great energy you
guys a little bit remind me of each
other a little bit actually
um I think that's a compliment yeah it
is a compliment I like the mess he's um
he's good people I love how big of a
football fan he is I do appreciate it he
is he's a he's a he's he's a good dude
he um but he would talk about how like
you had to like pay your I mean you
would he's like you get there there's
fans that are excited about the airport
but then you just you have to go get
your rental car you have to [__] get
in you have to drive two and a half
hours then you have to go uh run through
the script in the ring it's like I'm
like damn it's a lot that's a lot and
then you have to perform yeah think
about like think about like you have to
put oil on your body dude like like you
like us like you'd have to wet your hair
back and like so it doesn't get all in
your face and and then some of those
guys are out there performing like not
every match is like super long but like
there are guys that go out there and do
like the 25 minute matches like that's a
lot of cardio oh yeah oh that's like two
more yeah yeah like one in Orange Theory
but people are beating the [__] out of
each other in it with chairs dude it's
nuts just like the time that it like the
time and then like the physicalness and
like they don't get time to rehab and
like do all that stuff they don't have
access to all that stuff like I have a
facility I get to go to every day yeah
they're at the hotel pool
hot tub hopefully it has a bathtub so I
can take a hot bath tonight to warm up
my legs yeah it's crazy you probably go
to the yeah you go to like the ice
machine you open it up and uh you know
half of The Hardy Boys are there
whatever like damn this is crazy
yes I think it's a tough it's a really
really tough gig I just think there's a
lot of things that are a little bit
behind the scenes of a lot of
performances that you just see the
the show yeah and you don't see like a
lot of the other stuff that has to go on
no um dude I I like I always enjoy
whenever I'm backstage and you can like
catch someone like a like a tag team
with the other Tag Team fake going
through the match it's so cool to see
that stuff it's just it's really
interesting because I'm like wow like
there's a lot of intricacies to this and
like there's a because there's always a
build up to the match and then like you
just for them to know it and because
it's not memorized but like they're out
there trusting each other that the guy's
gonna do what they expect them to do
yeah it's crazy and if you have to
memorize something you're dumb it's
[__] hard oh my gosh it has to be so
difficult oh dude I was you know I
wouldn't say I'm yeah I'm like kind of
you know but I've definitely been dumb
and had to memorize [__] and not done it
it just it
there's like there are some things that
are just hard and it is what it is and
dude never studying in high school and
you'd be like you closed the book he's
like I have no idea I study for 90
minutes and have no idea oh my gosh dude
that was yeah like I'm like okay where I
just there's two hours okay and now I
gotta go do the whole thing again
because I forgot what I just read yes
awesome oh my God I was a big I had to
highlight everything and then I'd have
to go back and then read the highlights
and then sometimes I'd be like why did I
highlight the whole page I might as well
not have a [__] highlighter I should
just read the whole thing again oh my
God that was the worst oh my goodness
yeah dude you're the only one refilling
your highlighter I'll be sitting there
and like the owner that wouldn't be
highlighted is like the like I skipped
outward I was like well although the
other things are pretty important so I
guess I don't need a highlighter I'll
just read the whole thing again you'd
even highlight the picture you like draw
like a highlight around the picture like
this yeah and this oh flip it oh that
page too okay oh my goodness hey could I
snag a water by chance yeah for sure
please and thank you we got another you
have to pee or anything
uh thank you for asking it's very kind
of you oh well it creeps me out being
around somebody that has somebody has a
full bladder and they and they're just
staying like to be talking to someone
and they're knowing that they're full of
pee at the same time something about
that creeps me out dude I am mildly
um like
what's it called what's like if you
don't like clo like tight spaces
claustrophobic claustrophobic yeah so
like airplane bathroom airplane
bathrooms I don't do all in those it is
weird in there dude it's super tight so
like I go five hour flights without
going to the bathroom wow constantly but
you could probably hold a lot more urine
than a regular person sure but like I
mean like there are guys that go two to
three times on a flight and like I'm so
hydrated it's not like I'm not drinking
water like I go through like two of
those big Essentia bottles stuff like
that and it's just like no I'm just
uncomfortable I'll hold it I'm good well
I just ride the bag just ride it and
like there are times like and like like
in the last like two years like we've
like kind of like changed the plane that
we were on so there's a bigger bathroom
so I feel less bad about it but like
it's still like it's it's not my
favorite thing to do I get it's weird I
don't like small close places like you I
don't think you could pay me an amount
of money got a submarine oh yeah
can you imagine going down like a
thousand feet under water and if
anything happens you're just implode and
you die
well first of all it seems so dumb why
would you do it why would you go down
there like what were they doing down
here like like 50 years ago too like
right like what are we doing like and
like who said like who built I was like
this is gonna work how many how many
people got into a submarine and went
down 500 feet like in the prototypes and
it just imploded on I'm like ah that
wasn't the right model we're gonna fix a
couple things
like who's the test at me for that also
you put like seven guys in a [__]
tank right and if they pop up in another
country they're gonna get five there's
seven of them yeah what's going on oh
that'll that like get a lion your wife
the whole time that's gotta be the
hardest part of it where were you yeah
let's just say I'm underwater man I'm
hanging with the boys
dude yeah no like so yeah like I'm
mildly claustrophobic and it's just like
I don't what about that helmet though no
it's just it's where my body like I've
been a lot of MRI machines I've just
been football like that's just my job
like I get banged up there's certain
things you gotta look at I had um at the
combine before my rookie year I had to
get like six MRIs in one night it wasn't
really fun but one of them was either do
both my shoulders because I've both my
labrums I tore them in high school I
never had surgery on them and so like
I've never really had shoulder problems
I can't throw football very well
um but uh like the NFL teams wanted to
see MRIs of them they wanted to get
their own pictures and so they put me in
a smaller MRI machine and I had to sit
like this and it was an hour and 45
minute MRI because they did both
shoulders at once and that was that was
a very difficult time for me like I was
I took I sleep and memorize too for some
reason the noise like knocks me out but
I woke up with about 45 minutes left and
I like you know like have you ever been
in MRI oh yeah yes but like you know
like you squeeze the panic button
basically it took me a lot to not
squeeze that button like it was that was
that was one of the most cluster folks
I've ever been I it was off I was in a
full sweat there wasn't a fan so it's
hot full sweat I was like oh my it
getting out of that was one of the best
moments of my life dude like an escape
room kind of dude it was just like worse
one and it's like ten thousand dollars
like okay here's one would you rather
drown or get buried alive
let me think about it for a second
all right let me think about the second
one what was the second one buried alive
or drown
yeah just let me think about buried
alive
but you're in a wood box 10 feet
underground oh bro put me a little
closer no 12 feet oh come on you ever
see Kill Bill when she breaks out and
climbs out of the hole uh I don't know
if I have or not I don't know which one
that is but there's a scene where she's
literally in there and she's like
punches the Box breaks through and she
climbs out of a grave
you're not getting out of the box
there's nothing you can do you're not
getting out but at least just put me at
two feet so I feel like I can you're not
gonna
oh he was sick you're not good enough
dude uh so these are conversations I
have with my friends so buried alive
right yeah so well live you're gonna be
in there you're gonna coffin basically
right but you're gonna be able to first
of all you'll be able to convince
yourself okay I'm dot I'm like doing
like a cleanse or whatever I'm dieting
no like a guy Larry just looks he goes
you're gonna go in this box I'm gonna
put you in the ground okay you're not
getting out
and that's it
and there's no chance you're getting out
what would you rather do oh I put me in
the water man you think we just go to
sleep you just pass out
but no you don't pass out dude you ever
been no but like think about you you and
like that's what isn't that like the
Navy Seals training they they drown you
and then they resuscitate you
that's no that's I think that's like the
mob or something no that's a real thing
dude yeah that's a that's a real
training thing do that look it up Navy
Seals drowning one another that's a
thing dude I swear to God really now
probably I mean who knows what the [__]
they're doing well so like you have to
be prepared for anything and then you
got like you have to save your teammates
life [__] like that and so but sorry
about it what you're saying yeah it's
like yeah and so like I would rather I
think just go underwater and pass out
from not being able to breathe because
loss of oxygen but that's but then you
could be alive you could be in that box
for 24 hours 20 what do you know like
days think about it you could be there
for days dude you're not gonna be in the
yeah wouldn't you oh does that sound
terrible I don't know how big is how
little is the box like you have like two
inches on each side oh God I thought you
meant like one of those Aaron Rodgers
drug boxes that he was in yeah what do
you think he did in there oh I'm sure
well I I don't know if he did like
Ayahuasca I know he was like wouldn't it
be aggressive to do like uh like a hard
psychedelic in that area like being in
that dark hole well I think it was I
think it was like a nice enough I think
it was the room was like about this it
was probably about 300 square feet
so I think it was like no like I don't
know man in the dark that's not for me
like that I under like I I don't
understand it like I appreciate him for
like you know good for you for wanting
to try that I don't know if I will ever
do that but
okay it was something yeah the depth I
think it was about like a site deprivate
or like just like what would happen if
you don't if you're not without the
stimulus you know yeah for sure and like
there's no phone there's no
communication with anybody else like
you're literally alone with your
thoughts you're alone with your thoughts
which is see what your thoughts yeah
it's just like go for him like I don't
know how old Aaron is but he's been in a
league for a long time he's gonna be in
the Hall of Fame right so it's just like
he has a Super Bowl uh he has what I
think he has multiple MVPs like he's a
Hall of Famer so like do you want to
continue to play football he doesn't
like I mean I like I have to it doesn't
have to if he doesn't want to so it's
like do you do I still want to do this
like do I still love the game that I you
know that I grew up playing and so and
and I don't know if that's what his
reasoning was but like I think that's
what it would be and so like if that's
what you want to do like to get along
with your thoughts I I get that I'm not
ready for that like I don't need that in
my life right now but hey maybe when I'm
35 like maybe maybe that's something you
want to do so like I'm not going to
judge him for it it's wild and now I
know about it and like well I have that
in my back pocket if I ever just want to
disappear for four days and it's Brave
of him kind of in a way to do it because
a lot of guys are afraid to I think you
know I know he's friends with Aubrey
Marcus and uh they aubry's big into like
uh psychedelic medicines and like
um just like templates of therapy and
stuff like that right huge into it like
just different types of therapy oh even
all types of stuff like like muscle like
like even like being under the influence
of certain things and then like doing
certain things to your muscles to
release like Memories like and this is
like all that's cool I'm paraphrasing
but Arby's oh that's cool deep into that
world right and I think a lot of guys
would be especially at Aaron's level of
popularity he's famous famous right
would be embarrassed to not embarrassed
but would probably feel uncomfortable
talking about that especially he brought
me he brought it up and he talked about
it like on the Pat McAfee show too the
boys love them but like they uh like
just to bring that up and like and it's
Aaron Rodgers like everything that he
says on to the media like everybody's
gonna do that's all they got everybody
it's a clip like any if he's says
anything out of like out of line or kind
of controversial like that's a headline
on hundreds of newspapers or like online
online newspapers so it's just like for
him to go out and say that like that was
the only thing anyone talked about for
the next three days oh yeah it was crazy
all over social media like the meme
Pages everyone making fun of them for
but like for him to go out there and
talk about it like I didn't even know
that was a thing and I'm kind of that's
cool like again not for me right now but
but it's a factor who knows who knows
like I might want to do that someday
yeah yeah they have all types of things
like that like there's like a camp you
can go to where no one talks for like a
week and then I think you can do like
you still interact with people yeah you
still interact and if you do two weeks
so it's like charades I guess
whoa so like if you know sign language
is that cheating oh I don't know but
you'd have to bring someone that also
knows it otherwise
otherwise people to think you're into
some [__] you're like just like in a
bunch of gangs
just don't stop that's funny dude
but um that's cool you want to go to one
oh dude I would go I bet it would be
something really cool to do probably
with a friend or your wife or something
like that'd be interesting just be
interesting like hey let's just go have
this weird experience it's gonna be fun
we're going to be around each other but
we can't talk for a whole week it's
gonna be really weird yeah it'd be
really really weird you know I don't
know I don't know if my wife would like
that too much
um but I think like I would bring like
one of my buddies on that like just I I
think I would try to make him talk and
try to make him laugh oh yeah that would
be you yeah but you can't be that weirdo
who's [__] tickling some dude in the
distance all the time I mean you can if
you want man that's your call it's on
you man people are just staying away
from you the whole time you just think I
kind of gotta try to get people to
squeal okay oh my God like who's this
[__] silence
Anarchist over here but Aaron Rodgers is
also interesting he's not married no so
it's kind of how how old is Aaron
Rodgers I'm gonna go 36 okay so he's
getting to be at a point in his life it
kind of seemed like he's just he he
seemed like he's definitely kind of a
Searcher kind of dude you know yeah I
think I think look like
39 yeah he's 39 years old I will like I
think at his point his I mean again like
I have no idea but like at some point
football is not the only thing in my
life right like I'm not just a football
player like there's more sides me than
that and I think he's been playing
football since he was probably five
seven years old for the last 30 years I
bet she wants to find out like who else
like what other parts of me like what
else do I love as much as football it's
a good point man I think that that's I
think that probably happens for a lot of
guys who get
stuck into one uh or who starts so young
in something because then you're like at
some point you're like as of
did I get put into this did I really
obviously I've Loved this at certain
points and it's been a great big part of
my life but are there other things yeah
that I want to do that I don't even I'm
so been so stuck in this vein
that I don't even know what they are
yeah like you just you missed like you
missed that window and like granny like
I don't know if you would like I
wouldn't trade my opportunity like I
love playing football like who knows
like there could be something else that
like I might have loved to do it if I
just would have given it a shot like
maybe I love the cross maybe if I like
uh yeah I mean like what if I did that
or like what if I wanted to be the
Brittany Griner of [__] lacrosse I
think dude you'd have been a [__]
gangster that's a [__] compliment oh
dude you would have been insane and look
crossed yeah actually but it wasn't
offered where I lived and so like who
knows like I could have enjoyed that
like I don't know so like maybe he's
like at some point you want to figure
out what else what else you love you
know I think that a lot about like even
some of my friends that are athletes
that are black guys actually sometimes I
think because a lot of young black men
they didn't have any other opportunities
except for athletics that's it so I
start to wonder sometimes like if that's
even a bigger thing in there sometimes
Community or that you'll start to see
like because they didn't have any other
choice no or there weren't as many
options to get I mean not as many
outlets right not as many outlets like I
mean unless opportunities too yeah sure
so it's like damn I wonder how many of
those guys start to feel like man is
this something that I even wanted to
even not wanted to do was it more like
do I love the game or is it like more of
my only choice I had that was my like
that's what I had to do it's kind of
interesting it is interesting I think I
think well one like football is really
hard if you don't love it Like It's
really because like what you put your
body through what you put like the
stress levels through like we put our
like I know every like our professions
like when you're out there you know for
like to perform and like that's how like
people watch you and stuff like that
it's like there's a stress that comes
out because you can make one bad play
and like that's the only thing everybody
on Twitter is yelling at you for and
telling you that you're a piece of [__]
and so like there's a there's a mental
stress to it there's a physical stress
to it time away from your family like I
just said like I I my Nashville's my
home I haven't this is my second day
back since July 24th that's so wow yeah
so it's crazy and I love it here like I
love Nashville I love being a part of
this city
um and I live in San Jose California for
for seven months out of the year so
which is it's wild because it should
yeah it just it blows me away
yeah you know even yeah I mean I can
relate to a lot of that I love being
here and I feel like I kind of get to
know it in increments because I'm always
going to be gone it's very hard for me
to start a relationship with someone
yeah then I don't know I'm gonna be able
to upkeep you know it's like um I've
already kind of written off that I might
even be able to you know I would like to
have a spouse you know and so it's like
I think
uh maybe there's a possibility in the
next year and a half I'll meet somebody
but I know for the next year and a half
I'm probably going to be touring a lot
and so it's like I haven't written it
off but it's like I know it's going to
limit my chances for sure if I'm in the
same place being able to like um have a
commitment that I'm there with all the
time you know yeah no I do get that and
it's also but like you have to be kind
of selfish because this is your window
of opportunity right like if it's it's
out there for you Nick you could say no
but like will that opportunity ever come
again yeah right so like might as well
take advantage of it and like you know
it's that you don't like not everybody
has to do that like it's it's a life
choice if you want to do that and you're
making sacrifices but it's like
I mean dude I guess if you like if you
enjoy doing it go do it and like you can
pause for a year and a half like
you're like you're still going to be
here scary though to do it so if I said
George Kittle won't you take a year and
a half off right a footballer off of
like football oh no that no that's what
I was talking about dating taking a year
how year and a half off of dating like
oh right right I see what you're saying
I thought you meant to take a year and a
half off of doing it no don't do that
don't do that like I'm saying I see this
opportunity dog it's right there go do
it you're doing a great job so just keep
doing it well thanks man yeah yeah it's
but it's interesting it's like uh
yeah you have to look at that and kind
of figure that out
um I have to pee real fast go forward
all right right back
what um
do you
Celsius
what is it it's just cell it's like has
a little bit of caffeine in it
so it's just called Celsius
I like it my friend Dustin Poirier
drinks it oh really that's how I learned
about it do you watch any UFC a little
bit I'm involved with pfl
the professor of Fighters League oh
really yeah gone to that a little bit
and they do what fighting it's same
thing yeah it's the same thing it's like
kind of a tournament style though so
like it's like they have so if you win
the first round you just move on second
round I tell you that's how they decided
who wins the belt oh wow it's kind of
cool it's on ESPN plus I think yeah PSP
and plus that seems a lot more almost
realistic in the what the value of the
belt is yeah that's what it's cool like
and I'm not like I'm not huge in the UFC
stuff like I'll watch like the big
fights like I enjoy watching that
um do I don't follow it religiously like
a lot of people do but
um I I mean I have the most respect for
those people because it's insane oh it's
crazy cue like they like
that when they go into the ring like
when they flip the switch there's no
like there's no buffer it's like I'm
trying to kill this person like in
football like it's it's a little bit
like you have that mindset to an extent
but like they're actually in there until
someone pulls them off of them it's
crazy to me yeah that's wild yeah
there's it's a different level of um of
violence that you're willing to do
um we have a friend Drake you know Drake
yeah I just did his podcast you did yeah
watch the block on oh it's so cool
episode man that's pretty impressive
congratulations dude I love Drake he's
such great energy dude dude he is bro
there's something of yeah he's like he
reminds me of like he reminds me of uh
mankind a little bit for sure dude he's
a psycho yeah well so here's a fun Drake
story
um my senior day in college he played
fullback with me at Iowa that's how I
know him oh that's how you guys know
yeah and so also then like I was number
46 he was number 45 and so our lockers
are next to each other for like three or
four years that's how they do it by
numbers and I when they and we got a new
Locker our old locker room it was like
you would go
uh it was like 1 through 50 and then
like every other number was 51 through
99. okay and so like it'd be one and
that'd be 51
252. people some people would quit
because of that it's confusing it was
weird your lockers put like the new one
it was like one started here and it just
kind of went around and so it was yeah
so 45 46 were next year so we became
friends and then uh this past oh sorry
my senior day uh so my fifth year we're
playing Nebraska and we'd beat the shot
of them because uh oh because of Will
Compton oh no so he beat Iowa once he
always talks about that or something
like that I don't know he's always
talking about something dude he's he
always talks about something it is what
it is but he looks like a premature baby
on [__] pre-workout
dude
that's really funny dude wow well that's
tough for you dog you went to Nebraska
and you look like that that's super
tough wow sorry but Drake I mean I
didn't say any of that no you didn't no
what are you talking about no idea who
said that yeah but sorry but uh Drake
yeah my very first play we're running an
inside Zone he's at fullback and I'm
blocking somebody and I just hear a snap
and I turn around and Drake's leg is
Twisted he broke it himself no he like
he he hits he hits somebody and then
someone landed on it and just snapped in
half first play cause he's nuts oh he's
a psycho and it's awesome but there's a
cool we have a cool photo where it's
like he's getting carted off and he's
basically like telling us all to beat
the [__] out of him it was pretty
awesome pull it up Steven you just full
of Drake cool yeah hulik yeah I know
Drake kulick or yeah we're in it
together it's a fun photo but I'll say
like he spent this entire last offseason
he lives he moved to Nashville to train
with me so every day yeah because he
invited me out a couple times to you
you're a barn out there oh yeah so he he
came out yeah that's when he broke his
leg whoa yeah it's super aggressive
um I've never seen him there's us three
right down there in the middle left left
left down yeah it's me 46.
oh wow yeah I don't know there's one
holder there somehow
yeah well I don't and 52 dude I could
have been 52 I'm just saying he that I'm
just saying thick boy out of Iowa that's
off the line right there oh yeah that's
all [__] yeah well that's that that
was us hanging off first yeah look at
that boy but he uh yeah so he came down
he trained with me uh we did four days a
week
um he was fantastic and it was always
too like he's such a he's a great dude
to have around too because he's very
aware of his surroundings and also being
around someone that knows like Jiu Jitsu
and how to fight it's really I enjoy
that having someone that he could just
flip a switch anymore like someone tried
to [__] with me he would 100 have my
back at any moment I appreciate people
like that and it could be a big dude too
like that value of knowing that skill
and you're friends with you it's well
but also it changes the game of like if
it's a big dude versus a little dude
sure that game's changed dude yeah
you're not wrong I was like it was fun
we went to uh in Scottsdale for the
Super Bowl because that's where he lives
now uh I had tickets to uh the Drake
concert up there and so I we go to it
and uh on our way out because it's com
it's crazy those concerts they have they
tried it they pack like 20 000 people
into a place that fits five thousand oh
yeah and like there's it's just it's
it's it's crazy
um but like there's like TMZ and all
this Paparazzi outside waiting for
people and
I like two guys kind of put my camera in
my face and he just kind of goes up and
throws an elbow into a rib cage and the
dude just kind of drops clears a path
for me I get into a car and he stopped
right behind me I was like you good he
was like what are you talking about not
throwing under the bus straight but that
was awesome it was so sick so don't get
sued please
um no he would help me out when I would
go to uh the national MMA he would help
me all the time and just like always
like just a good teacher but yeah he has
a great energy man and he's still
fighting he's yeah he's training like
full time yeah he sends me clips all the
time I love it and no like what's
awesome like he his so like yeah I keep
talking about like the switch that you
have to flip his switch like his
football switch is still flipped on and
it just kind of always so he just kind
of has this like this anger and like
this violence of energy and I like I
really because not everybody's there's
not a lot of people like that and so
being around someone that has that kind
of that energy to them that's just
violence I really appreciate that and
he's a great dude he's super kind and
he's wonderful but like like there's not
a lot of people that are triggered like
that or like wired like that and I like
those people yay do you I you like the
violence I like people that are just I
like people that are wired differently
just high energy not even high energy
but he's just like controlled anger
and he's just kind of like ready to go
at any moment and I appreciate people
like that because it's hard to be like
that all the time it wears on you oh I
could imagine it's hard to just [__]
have all the fire inside of you but and
it's just like burning it all the time
right but people don't want any fire
outside so you gotta [__] just walk
around like a furnace dude I know it's
like you either have to put it out or
keep it super low but like his is like
at a medium anger all the time and I
really I like that that's interesting
it's a great way to describe him he yeah
he's a special dude man
um what else I was going to ask you
about oh what was it like when you were
a kid did you like have a did you have
like crazy Halloween costumes and stuff
like did you dress up like a [__]
yeah what'd you do um so it's fun fact
my so I said my mom had nine sisters
she's one of ten girls her dad was
Halloween was his birthday and so and
like the dad that had nine kids ten ten
daughters ten daughters yeah basically
yeah his birthday was Halloween
that's really funny yeah that's really
funny that's a good one I'm gonna tell
my mom that one I don't know if that's a
government I don't know anything in your
mouth that's really funny that's all
that's awesome but so and we had like I
would say like let's just say like six
of the six of the daughters all lived
like within an hour or so so and they
all had kids and so like we'd have
Halloween parties and like we'd have
like 30 to 40 people show up for
Halloween and like 25 of us are kids and
so we would just basically go through
these small Iowa towns with like all
these like just 25 deep and it was
really fun but Batman was a good that
was one of my top characters to be I
really like the Grim Reaper like I had
the like the nylon mask you'd pull on
your face and I just walk around the
Scythe wouldn't say anything yeah I was
kind of creepy I really enjoyed that one
the Grim Reaper yeah he doesn't get
people don't dress up like the Grim
Reaper very often no not not anymore no
I wouldn't I don't think I've ever seen
anybody be the Grim Reaper that was like
my number one costume from like five to
nine probably wow love the grimy really
until I grew out of it maybe maybe like
like four to seven but like but that's
just interesting I don't know any I've
never heard anybody say they were the
Grim Reaper dude you said you had like a
skull for a face you were a cool robe
and you just got to carry a big Scythe
yeah now to hit my cousins with it all
the time yeah we have that many [__]
Cousins you can if you lose a few you
lose a few you know if someone falls
behind they fall they fall behind the
Pack's still deep man that's crazy wolf
pack man you got to survive that's wild
bro that's awesome
um what was your costume my costume let
me think oh we got a book my dad was
like a senior citizen so you would
always pick messed up [__] at the last
minute so we had me and my brother were
both Raggedy Ann one year
that's awesome oh it was horrible dude
and we're so pissed we're in the [__]
yard just two raggedy hands beating this
[__]
that's all young male children dressing
[__] drag dressed in Halloween drag
beating the [__] out of each other just
[__] it was always a nightmare dude
yeah we that's awesome
oh my mom would have to work so my day
was he was in charge of getting us ready
for Halloween and stuff like that and it
was just [__] horrible one time we
wanted face paint we wanted like white
face paint and to do uh
to do like skeletons or whatever you
know be skeletons and my Dad forgot it
or whatever and so
I remember he poured us like a little
bowl of like
I want to say no it was like
he poured us like a little bowl of um
of like half and half cream or whatever
so I remember me and my brother like
trying to get this [__] and he's like no
you're not using enough and I remember
[__] just like
then or we go outside like all the
neighborhood cats are [__] coming
over like just just everything was just
so [__] it was just so ridiculous oh
dude so it was like it was always like
this weird Halloween
um and then Halloween's a crazy concept
but anyways it is kind of crazy it's
good though I love it yeah let like be
weird oh Halloween was it yeah Halloween
was good
um what else oh what about
uh
uh what about like so with that big of a
family did you guys do like big family
events and stuff would you get pretty
crazy every year it was literally up
until
um what was that summer at summer 2019 I
think it was we did uh we had the Cragar
family reunion and my mom's maiden name
is Craig or k-r-i-e-g-e-r and so they uh
we'd have a family reunion and we used
to have it like in Iowa at like this
kind of another it was like I can't
remember what it was called but it was
like this small town and it's like out
in the woods was like this
um just like big building that it was
like a little hotel I guess but they
they had like 80 rooms and so like each
family would get a room and we literally
we'd like we had almost the entire
family like we had like a hundred and
like 12 people there one time and like
we do Wiffle ball tournaments and then
like kind of and I usually did when I
was a kid like but you'd have I mean I'd
say like 80 of the people 80 out of 120
80 out of 110 would play and you'd have
these huge Wiffle ball tournaments we do
kickball a lot of card games but like
that was the most fun because I went to
those when I was like between the ages
of like 7 and 14. oh yeah I'll do so I
was just out there having the time of my
life playing in the woods getting food
and you just can hang out with all your
best friends all the time and like I was
close to my cousins too because like I
said we all lived in Iowa so we were all
like I've lived with some of my cousins
before like throughout my life so it's
like we're all really good friends and
so like those family units were really
fun dude that's such a well that's so
amazing who gets to have an experience
like that not very many people and like
that many family members that close too
and like people like we had family lived
in Indiana family lived in Colorado and
everybody would always come back from it
but like Larry yeah I'd say like from
age like nine to probably 16 like we had
like a seven year window there where
like over 100 people would show up every
time wow it was pretty cool dude that's
awesome it was really fun
um yeah that's just so cool that's one
thing that's neat I think about a lot of
a lot of the Midwest there were some big
families you know especially a lot of
church families you'd see a lot of
church families and they'd roll up
they'd always had that church van you
know and they got down one of my cousins
has one of those because he is like I
think they what do they have I would say
like 12 13 kids now yeah they roll up
with the with the white van it has
Windows so thank goodness
bro if your family rolls up
20 kids get out yeah oh that's a
kidnapper so thankfully they got windows
on their car yeah no women get out bro
that's yeah that is definitely it was
just like oh my gosh they have so many
kids and it's like hey I love that like
they're they're a fantastic family it's
fun but just like that's a lot of that's
a lot of people it's a lot do you guys
will you think you guys have a big
family do you have thoughts about that
or not yeah I mean I'd say like uh my
wife has one brother I have one sister
but like we both want to have I have
like three to four kids that's good yeah
that's right that's that'd be a dream
yeah be really fun yeah I think it'd be
nice especially if you can I think these
days especially too if you can afford to
have them that's probably a big part of
it
um and then like my wife she's six foot
tall and she oh I've seen her she played
basketball at Iowa so she's an athlete
so like I think my kids will be good for
college actually I know they will be
their ball they're going to be Ballers
yeah that's all like two but for sure
like nil deal year two yeah I mean two
years old two years old yeah
age too
that'd be awesome yeah but yeah no I I
would prefer a bigger family because
this is what I was thinking about this
too because like I said so she's in a
family of four I'm in a family of four
if me and her have four kids and we're a
family of six neither one of us has ever
interact like we've had friends that
have families like that but like I've
never been responsible in a family of
four kids and so like I'll be a whole
new interaction for me like I've never
been like I've never I've never had a
brother so like I know like I had
cousins that are brothers I have friends
that are like Brothers to me but like I
never had an actual brother so like if I
have two sons or can you imagine Three
Sons like what that was interaction
would be like I've never experienced
that before so like it'll be a
completely new experience for me too
which is I think that's really cool
yeah dude that'd be oh I think the
family Dynamics totally different than
what I was used to oh yeah to see what
that's like yeah like I think that's
just gonna be really interesting yeah
yeah having a brother is pretty cool man
I know right like yeah I'm so thankful I
had a sister like she like she's taught
she taught me a bunch
um I definitely like I didn't fight my
sister she beat the [__] out of me
sometimes that was about it but like I
didn't really have an opportunity to
fire because she was she was like 5 10
at the age of 10 Just Whipped up on wow
was she dude she was like she was a
stallion back in the day like she's like
when she played high school basketball
like she could fight me and beat me up
pretty easily damn so like I was like
yeah what do you need to see some of
that footage I think if she didn't only
fans of just that you want to see my my
17 year old sister's highlights I'd
watch a 17 year old girl beat up George
Kittle yeah for nine dollars a month
yeah young George Kittle yeah sure you
know what honestly it's not that weird
when you say it like that yeah young
jerk kid I'm not saying like I don't
need any lingerie oh I'm just saying
I'll send you a video of my scissors
beating the [__] out of me in a couple
days I see her
um when you look at uh when you how long
does it take you to forget about the
season and start to think about the next
one how long does that kind of pain take
I can only imagine especially if you're
a very competitive person yeah you have
such a great
uh Team what is the um how long does
that take how long does that take
um
honestly it's like kind of like waves
dude in the ocean like
right afterwards like it hits you a lot
and then like the farther away you get
from it the waves don't hit as often and
so you just kind of like it kind of goes
away but like it's still like I lost a
Super Bowl it still sucks like I don't
like it sucks like I wish I would have
won it would have been really fun like
that's a dream like I said and when you
get close like we've lost two NFC
championships games back to back like it
sucks but like
the great thing is is I made it out I I
just try to take as positive as I can I
made it out healthy
um I can train right away again we still
have a very talented team and so like
yes it sucked but hey I'm still very
confident that we have like we have an
opportunity to win a Super Bowl so yeah
it really it sucks but like you get on
with it and like there are other parts
of your life that you know like kind of
pick you up right like I have a great
support system whether it's my family or
my wife like I have a great support
system I have great friends I have a lot
of friends who like deal with the same
stuff and so just like a lot of football
friends who like so like it's not a
support group but it's just like you
have people that go through similar
stuff so like you're not alone in it
that's the one benefit of football like
at the end of the year there's only one
team that wins so 31 other teams are all
dealing with some of the same [__] yes
you can call almost anybody literally
like it's really hard to win a Super
Bowl so like yeah if you want to talk
about it or stuff like that now I don't
think you really need to talk about it's
just kind of like you just got to get
you get it just takes a couple weeks
really like like the first two to three
weeks afterwards really suck but like
now that I'm back in Nashville and like
I'm like I said I'm healthy and I can
train it goes away pretty quick after
that but like the perspective probably
starts to switch to the Future a little
bit and also like if and like so my
first two years our team wasn't very
good and so like my I didn't go to the
playoffs so like when your season ends
in like December it's you're kind of
like all right well yeah it kind of we
sucked this whole year but like you're
also like when you know you're not in
the playoffs
it's
you you're you're like you're playing
for yourself and you've got to put
yourself out there and like you want to
like you got to put good stuff on tape
like you can't just give up but like
there are like there's a the energy
changes the energy changes and it's it's
harder to get like eaten during the
middle of the game no not like that but
no I'm saying like this week to week oh
yeah like so like if you're like an 0-9
team like my rookie year we started on
nine oh yeah not very fun but like and I
was just and I was learning right not
even a team what do you even doing it
was brutal man it was really fun though
but it was brutal we had like 25 rookies
on the active roster it was like it was
wild but it was really fun but like once
the season ends because like you kind of
like Okay We're not gonna make the
playoffs like three weeks before like
your wife or like you're like you're
planning a vacation so you're like then
you have something else to look forward
it's just it's different than right than
going in the playoffs and like hey like
hey I have an opportunity like we went
to the whole season we're one of the
what seven teams that make the playoffs
on my side of the conference like we
have a shot to win and then it gets
taken out from and then you're like damn
but like if you know you're not gonna
like it's it's just it's two different
things and I've experienced both and I
think it's like I'd rather win a bunch
of games and then lose a heartbreaker
honestly like winning 12 to 13 games is
a lot more fun than losing 10 straight
oh yeah yeah it's like I'd rather do
that like and yes but does it suck to
lose at the end for sure it sucks a lot
but hey it's life it is what it is I'm
just gonna continue to grind and
continue to be a good football player
did you think when when Brock Purdy came
in
um what it would be like and there's a b
in here or something not B it's just a
safe animal
oh yeah it's probably if I hit it will
Peter get mad at me huh I don't think so
I don't even know who that is
you know what I honestly doesn't
surprise me yeah it's just
it's just I'm so distracted by this oh
you got it huh
I'm gonna put that outside okay okay
that was Lefty too it's not bad somebody
said Travis Kelsey can do that with a
falcon
just saying this is what I've heard
Falcons did you see the clip on
Instagram or the dude that hunts with a
falcon bro I've been falcon hunting
before like you and you see something
you just go wow and it's like a
superpower dude I don't know if I've
seen that that dude these guys are
driving with like a hawk or a falcon and
they're in a car they stop it or like I
think it might have been an ATV and like
they get off and they see something they
guy like starts running through the snow
and like there's a fox like 100 yards
away and he literally throws a falcon
and it's like perch on his arm ready to
jump out like it's like a swimmer diving
out and he just and you just see him
like coast along this like snow bank and
just claws pick it up and it brings it
right back wow nuts I saw I've seen that
clip a ton of times that thing's crazy
I've never seen that I don't think I'll
send it to you yeah please do man that'd
be nice to have yeah those those clips
are have you felt like nature is metal
oh yeah oh my God so [__] crazy it's
so crazy you're having like a nice
evening you know you're out [__] to a
nice dinner you pick at the phone and
it's a raccoon just eating it's young
and you're like
that page like one of the one of the
craziest things I ever saw on that page
was have you ever seen like the Moose
run through snow have you ever dude
look at a moose Jesus these guys dude I
was looking mooser massive animals oh
yeah they're very large and like there's
a clip of this thing running like 30
miles an hour just through six feet of
snow oh my god oh I'll relapse if I
watch this too much oh
dude these things are crazy I know this
isn't the one I've seen but look there's
a white guy eating a sandwich look at
this I leave it here
oh he's oh wait oh he's about to go
yeah I think he just runs right past him
here in a sec
try that
oh we picked the worst video where it's
just a guy it's just two guys eating a
sandwich watching a moose I know here he
comes no see this isn't the clip I think
that's a horse also oh there it goes oh
my God like what is that that's a Dodge
Ram can you imagine if he just like
chested like if you were Justified
you could take it on no really I'd cut
him I go right for his knees all right
the thing's knees and it's probably
gonna It's Gonna Knock my window give me
a concussion but I ain't going out like
that man
holy cow dude I'm take it from the side
like if I was a safety and that's the
tight end across the middle field I'm
gonna take a creative angle and try to
hit its back two legs right at the
ankles and take it out spin it out
that's what I would do God you can't
take that thing on full that's like
tackling Derek Henry remember have you
seen people like stifferent like you
know they're just highlights of him
slapping them to the ground that's what
that would be like that's you trying to
tackle Derek Henry I would do some other
way to get him you know now what if you
put lice in your field in the grass that
God in his hair at halftime he's itching
too much you can't hold on to the ball
when that happened to you too though
true but you'd risk it I know but you
know maybe as a defensive player I get
that oh I'd be so you just gotta think
of a new strategy who wants to go tackle
Derrick Henry oh no one that sounds off
you gotta hit him before he gets the
ball I know he gets three steps going
he's three steps in he's full speed and
then that's it's a 200 he's bigger than
I am and he plays running back wow
really so that's another thing that
blows me away like you've seen that so
like Derrick Henry plays running back
he's six foot dude he's like six four
six five 245 pounds oh my God Christian
McCaffrey plays running back and he's 5
like 210 pounds like they play the same
position or how about Robbie Gold's a
kicker he's 40 years old and then you
have guys like Trent Williams and they
play the same sport those comparison
photos always like freak me out you have
like you have the six foot six guys who
could you know kill somebody easily and
then you have the data for who's just
kicking footballs yeah he's just hunting
yeah just like how different everybody
is in the NFL it's like the it's the
biggest Melting Pot it's crazy that is
probably pretty wild hot and then you
also have a lot of Samoan players people
don't even realize huh do you guys have
a lot of Hawaiian or Samoan players
um we I've had them on my team in the
past like we have a Tongan uh oh wow
yeah Tao no hafanga we just call him
Hoff he was the first female pro this
year he had a great season in his second
year but like yeah he throws it whenever
he makes a big play he throws the T out
it's awesome dude it's so sick so cool
he has he just he's it's just a
different energy and people are wired
differently and I I that's what I love
about the NFL you learn so much about it
really yeah well like think about like
you have people who come from great
family backgrounds people come from
terrible family backgrounds you have
people who were all Americans in college
and people who are undrafted free agents
got cut by their first couple teams you
have guys who are first-round traffic
that's had success uh you have Mr
relevant uh Brock Purdy like everybody
has like such a different story the last
pick yeah last pick Mr relevant so like
this is the crazy like if you just if
you just take the time to listen to
Somebody talk and like you understand
them like and you're just open about it
dude it's the amount of stuff you can
learn from people is amazing like it's
it's really fun just to sit and talk to
guys What's the culture like over there
at with the 49ers it's amazing yeah it's
it's incredible I hear that this is a
regular fan you hear that they have a
really great culture over there that
John Lynch right is the guy so yeah
Lynch and uh coach Shanahan they've
brought in a lot of really good guys but
like real what it was was like I had a
really good rookie class
um and like we were like we had a great
rookie class and a lot of our rookies
were on the team but like wow and we
added some really good vet like Joe
Staley uh Garrett Selica those are two
vets that we had that were amazing
people
um and they knew how to play the game
the right way but they were both like
Father figures to a lot of the guys like
young because like I said we had like 25
rookies yeah so we had a lot of young
guys and so they're all learning from
like these guys so we had good vets so
guys learn like what matters and how to
treat people with respect and and so
like because you'd be surprised that's
not a thing that's taught everywhere
treating people with respect it's kind
of crazy yeah but like in a locker room
you kind of have to
um because you're working with them
every single day but like so we have a
we have a saw group of guys and it's
kind of elevated like so our best
players our captains are all very high
character guys and so like you either
with us or you're not and so you better
be a good person do yourself that you're
supposed to do and then play and so like
that's kind of our culture and it's it's
gone and we work really hard we hit
people really hard and hey we're very
violent football team but we still have
a good time is it a pretty selfless
environment over there does it feel like
because because like you don't even get
a ton of balls right like you don't get
a ton of balls but you have but you have
a lot of great assets on your team and
there's a lot of people that need to get
the ball yeah like so it's a point of
like everybody you want individual
success like I would love to be in the
Hall of Fame right
um and so but like to do that you do
need a certain amount of Statistics to
get there right so there's a there's a
certain type of selfishness like you
because there is like you wanna you
wanna be good you wanna make huge plays
you wanna you wanna play you want to do
stuff right
um so what's awesome about our team is
like we all like whether it's Debo
um Christian McCaffrey Kyle use check
ayuk's fantastic I love ayuk he's he's
just a different energy like you have
these guys like they are they're
selfless it's like if we're winning the
game and and like they're playing too
like they're playing at Highway they're
running great routes they're you know
blocking at a high level too but like
they're doing everything we're doing
everything we can so like whether it's
Chris McCaffrey or other running back
like Elijah Mitchell like to get them
into the end zone that's all I care
about like us winning games is all I
care about and so like yes I love the
personal accolades like you you want to
build that resume but I mean I would I I
would trade about yeah I mean I would
I'd rather win a Super Bowl than I think
this is an argument I've had in the
locker before like would you rather win
a Super Bowl or be in the Hall of Fame
I think it would have to be the Super
Bowl as a fan I don't know who's in the
Hall of Fame that's right I mean I'd
rather run a Super Bowl than me in the
Hall of Fame now being a boat like both
would be amazing but like if I had to
pick one like hey George you would
rather win this or do that I'd pick on a
Super Bowl 10 out of 10 times do you
think there are players that would
rather get the ball more than win the
game
there are
not on your team even though I'm sure
I'm trying to think like I think there
are certain players that like you have
to have the mindset that when like when
you get the ball like the more like
you have to have a mindset like when I
get the ball dude it looks [__] scary
oh dude it's not for everybody and it is
what it is who me the ball dude I throw
it back nope honestly yeah hey yeah not
me not me yeah no not me dude I do a
timeout yeah I feel like you just toss
them a lot of bounds like nah flip coach
my bad just drop it I'm good no but um I
think wow that's a good question
um there might be some guys that are
like Morse like stat hungry maybe but
they're not in our team I've never
really been with a guy that was like
that which has been awesome
um but like and there's there's guys who
have contracts who are like hey if I get
40 catches this season I get a bonus
right like we had a guy who
um we had a guy who he he was a backup
right but he's resigned because his
rookie deal is over and he had an
incentive in there that was if he got
over he had to break his receiving yards
from last year and he only had like 150
receiving yards but he doesn't play a
lot on offense he's a special teams guy
and and by like week five he broke it
and it was amazing because he got he got
like a multiple hundred thousand dollar
bonus because of it and so like yeah
like there is a selfishness to it
because who doesn't want to get paid an
extra 250 000 or something like that
whatever it was I'm not entirely sure
but like that's awesome like good for
you and like I'm encouraging like hey
Jimmy throwing the ball Brock Trey throw
that guy the ball so it's just like
that's pretty fun like so like when it
is like so there's there's selflessness
but there's also a selfishness to it to
an extent right but I'm lucky to be on a
part of a team that hey like Debo's a
superstar he's fantastic and he had a
gamer he had like 20 or he had 20
receiving yards and 20 rushing yards we
won by two touchdowns he's like I don't
care he's like we're winning I have
another option like we have another
opportunity to play next week like it is
what it is and he goes and I'll be right
when I get my opportunity I'll be ready
for it yeah and then you like we had a
playoff game he had a 74 yard touch here
and he had 120 yards receiving a
touchdown player of the game it's just
like we have those guys capable on our
team but we have six of those guys or
seven of those guys they're capable and
then it's just it's fun to be a part of
a team like that yeah because it's not
everywhere was McCaffrey pretty excited
when he got to go to your team yeah I
think he was yeah I mean just have a
change of pace I'm sure is exciting for
anyone yeah and also you're getting good
go to a team that has a chance to move
forward in the for sure and like he
talking to Christian like he loved
Caroline he loved his experience he has
a house here like that's where he
thought he was going to be for his whole
career and they traded them and I'm
getting to come to San Francisco where
especially it was fun too because I met
Christian like uh 2018 2019 and so we've
kind of been talking about like hey it'd
be really fun to like play together
because oh that's cool we run the hell
out of the football he's a really
talented running back right and so we've
always kind of joked about that he
actually sent me a photo it was pretty
funny we traded jerseys in 2019 and at
the bottom of my jersey I said see you
soon
now he's a Niner which is pretty sick
um you got to speak things into
existence Theo it's really true man I'll
we'll talk about that next we've got to
come back to that because I like that
stuff really I'm big into that but you
gotta um
so sorry but like he came to this
offense that we run outside Zone like a
lot of guys like a lot of offices you
kind of see big guys waddle we're
running as fast as we possibly can to
try to make the like we're trying to
move the line of scrimmage that way
while also moving it that way or that
way so it's like it's a lot more
movement and it's if you're a good
running back and you can see those Lanes
it's a lot easier to run it's like it's
more difficult to run that way you have
to have the opposite line and like
Titans that are built for that but when
you have an o-line tied in fullback like
combo that is talented and like and
Shanahan's very good at creating plays
we're one of like the best run offenses
in football and so like for him to be a
running back in that offense it's a
really good opportunity it's exciting
yeah I felt excited when he got because
even after your quarterback went out in
the in the championship game yeah he had
a great run right after that right oh
yeah the touchdown that was insane I
mean that was Herculean dude and so that
was like so exciting it was 18 Wham it
was 18 Wham yeah I I down block on the
defensive tackle which happened to be
Fletcher Cox big he's a big big deal
he's a big dude he's he's large God and
sometimes when you push in a large man
do you feel their stomach or where do
you put your hands on them oh God like
the only way to move big people you have
to hit them and you have to hit people
in the hip that's how you make a move oh
that's like when I'm blocking so like I
don't know do you know what you have any
idea what Gap scheme is
um you ever run power It's called Power
the Titan everyone blocks down and you
pull a guard from the opposite side to
kick somebody out so it's called Gap
scheme It's called Power right but on
that the entire coaching point is if
there's
all right real quick if I'm the right
tight end yeah and this is the offensive
tackle like this is the off attack right
here and we're going that way
and there's a guy standing right here
I'm aiming Mike my sh my left shoulder
pad is aimed on his hip because if I can
hit that hip his feet will move and then
the right tackle will pick him up and
he'll move him for me while I go up to
the linebacker to pin it so you're
creating a wall and the running back's
gonna be right behind us and so like my
target is that hip and I'm trying to hit
as violently and as like hard as I
possibly can because it doesn't matter
if you're 200 pounds or if you're 300
pounds if I get you in that hip it moves
your base and then if you're off your
base and getting hit by another big guy
you're screwed right and if it's that
fast and it's that fast and like they
don't know that place coming too it's
like that's where my advantage is and so
I have to like I'm like a coiled spring
as soon as they say and I'm diving
through that guy's hip to go up to the
second level so yeah I'm sorry gapsing
that's my run game so I love the Run
game yeah because we were talking about
like
I don't get the ball every play and I
don't want the ball every play I like I
like getting the ball it's fun to catch
the ball it's fun to run it like you
like running with a football in open
space and not getting hit is one of the
coolest things you can possibly do as a
human being what do you feel like just
driving real fast dude I have a smile on
my face I'm just like this is like it's
because it doesn't happen very often
it's hard to get that open in the NFL
because everyone's such good athletes
but when you're just running through the
space man it doesn't feel like it's
illegal yes like I feel like I'm a kid
who just like I just stole something I'm
just running as fast as I can and it's
it's such a it's such a thrilling
feeling but so I don't get to do that
all the time so like running routes is
fun but when you don't get the ball
running routes isn't really fun because
I just get tired and so when you're in
the Run game and the whole thing is like
it depends on me like the running backs
to help me he has to set me up but like
I have to hit this guy as hard as I can
and then there's all these fundamentals
whether it's your first step your second
step your inside hand where your outside
hand goes but like there's just art to
it and people that are really good at it
you see their technique and like what it
looks like and it's just it's really fun
for me I watch a lot of I like I love
watch off the line like run the football
and like hit people so like there's this
artwork to it so like I put I like I'm
the best friend blocking I've run
blocking tied in the NFL I do it
differently than anybody else does and
I've been doing it differently for like
my entire career and I like my first
year maybe not so much but like second
year on I kind of like figured out what
works for me and so
I I put as much effort as I can to that
so then what's great about the timing
position I can affect every single play
I can I can have a huge impact on every
single play in the football game like a
wide receiver who's on the back side of
an outside Zone going away from him if
he doesn't block the corner it might not
be a big deal every play that I'm in on
I have uh I have the opportunity to have
a huge impact whether it's Run play or a
pass play so like I love playing tight
end because I have the opportunity and
because I get to do all those things I'm
gonna do everything I can to be great at
all those things whether it's pass
blocking run blocking or running routes
and catching so like I'm the only
position that you really get to do
everything like we had to tied and throw
touch on a Super Bowl a couple years ago
the Eagles guy
um but like you got to do a little bit
of everything and I really appreciate
that so like I don't want to be an
average rum blocking tight end like I'm
240 pounds like I'm not like there's
tight ends are like Mercedes Lewis is
six foot six seven he's like 265. that
man he manhandles people and it's
different like we do two different like
we hit people differently but like I'm
like I want to be and he is a very good
Titan he's played for he's going to 18.
he's fantastic I'm just like
I want to be great at everything that
I'm asked to do so then I don't have to
get taken out for anything I want to
play every single thing you don't play
every snap I do play every snap yeah I
mean I played the most apps in my career
this year did you really yeah of my
career and I missed the first two games
which was crazy that's a lot of snaps
yeah I played like yeah I mean I played
like 98 of the snaps every single game
that's incredible man oh dude it's well
like I said your window's only so big so
like you might as well make the most
your window yeah I like and also I only
get to hit people for 17 weeks so yeah
like I don't get I don't get anybody I
have a huge blocking sled at my house so
I'm gonna hit I can't wait to hit that
tomorrow and when you dress it up like
certain players or anything no that's a
good question though that's fun I have
thought about that but no I don't know
who I would I don't know how I'd set up
it like there's not I don't really not
like very many people in the NFL there's
a couple guys that you know I don't care
about or
um I might not care for there's not too
many games like completely Circle a
calendar there's a couple just like
based on the player that I get to go
against but I don't have that issue very
much which I like everybody yeah like
what's one of those teams where you're
like I'm going against this team this
week
um the Rams that's a big one for us like
because they play us they play us the
exact same way every time and then at
the end of the day they have Aaron
Donald who's I mean oh yeah yeah besides
Trent wearing sorry Trent Williams and
Aaron Donald are the two best football
players in the NFL not even close like I
mean sorry Patrick homes is really good
like Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady like there
are other good players but like for
dominance at their position every single
snap Trev Williams Aaron Donald and Nick
Bose is getting there too he's gonna be
really good but like Aaron Donald like
eight time all pro like that's insane
yeah his whole career is he's all pro
but so when you play the Rams you have
the game plan for Aaron Donald because
if you only put one guy on him the
likelihood of him blowing up the play
and hitting the running back or the
quarterback in the backfield and making
them fumble significantly increases so
you have to so you have to completely
game plan for him you gotta plan for him
hugely yeah hugely and um so we have to
plan for him like huge and then
um
sorry so like and then like the way they
play their defenses they just try to
bottleneck us as much as they can so it
makes our outside Zone a little bit more
difficult
um and then they kind of played in this
like kind of a quarters thing where like
they keep everything in front of like
it's kind of Bend but don't break like
you can give up some small stuff but
you're not getting anything past this
and then they're gonna be very violent
they're going to come up in the Run game
um and so it's just like playing a team
like that where they're so like I'm in
my three-point stance you know and line
of scrimmage is like right here oh yeah
they have an outside linebacker who's
wider than you are and like a tilted
stance and a sprinter stance and the
second we say hike he's trying to run
through my face as fast he can that way
to not let me reach him
and they're like not every team does
that but it's very difficult to go
against because at that point it's just
kind of me saying all right who's gonna
hit who harder
every time every time
and like we've like and like there's
different ways like we you we sometimes
put a guy in motion and we'll like we'll
double team that guy because like having
to hit somebody an anchor I think is
easier than having to hit somebody and
then move because if I anchor the window
doesn't everybody runs into my back
feels like so if like if I go to block
you and the offensive Line's coming this
way and I stop my feet I'm gonna get ran
up on someone's gonna go through my legs
so like I have to hit you and then keep
my feet running so I'm running like the
people behind me are also moving people
towards me like if you're at the point
of attack you have to run and his job is
to not let me run damn it's wild so but
the Rams do a really good job of that
if you you do you think say if you coach
you coached me you trained me right yeah
ultimate training ultimate coaching do
you think I could play you know no
in the NFL or like pickleball pickleball
I think you'd be really good at you
pickleball come on man dude we have a
lot of guys that play it I love that
game what about in maybe the usfl
like what position you want dog huh I'm
saying anything on the field and you
were my trainer man I would never give
up you could long snap
have good lungs now but I mean you'd
have to how much do you weigh right now
probably 186 maybe four you'd have to go
to like 220. [__] dude well you have to
you have to you have to hold some weight
because like in the NFL when there's a
small Long Snapper they'll just put like
a defensive lineman on them and it blows
them up and it just crushes him oh yeah
so like there's a you have to have a
little size too at least
but you could do that I just won't have
to wake up and eat at night like in the
middle of the night like a baby dude so
in college I had a really difficult time
like I couldn't get past 225 I couldn't
do it for like three years and so in my
third year I drank eight Gatorade
protein shakes a day and like literally
I had so like let's just say I wake up
at 6am for my lift I drink a protein
shake then I get to my lift and before I
get before I start the lift before I
start the warm up I drink another
protein shake I go through the warm-up
come in drink a protein shake before I
get on the scale this is just try to
keep my weight on uh after the lift I
drink a protein shake I take three or I
think I'm at four I think I'm at four
there I leave and then for lunch I have
a protein shake I'm in class I have a
protein shake is your truck just full of
dirty protein shaking yeah like do you
ever see the old Gatorade cans yeah like
those big thick ones no I'm lying tea
hold on hold that up look up Gatorade
protein shake can't alumin like metal
can but I would drink those add so many
of them in my house and then I'd have
one with then right before I go to bed
and then I'd set an alarm uh if I was
really struggling if I would set alarm
for 3 A.M or no 2 A.M and then four and
I have them again yeah just to drink
them because that was the easiest thing
for me I didn't eat like I don't know
yeah that thing dude you could kill
someone with that like it was it was a
brick I didn't even seen that yeah I
think that's available to the just no to
the public it's not available anymore
but so like I literally I was insane man
I know you know or how something off
about a product has to be that's not
available I think you have to go out of
your way well yeah that's actually weird
I didn't even know a Gatorade did
protein until I got to Iowa and I was
like oh whoa no one knew it until just
now when you told us probably every
college football athlete knew that was a
lot of places but yeah so that was uh so
you gotta have that weight on so that's
a number one thing you need to be able
to play you really have to have some
weight on you yeah to an extent like I
mean like I was like I said I was right
if I weigh 225 pounds right now I
wouldn't be in the NFL wow yeah I mean I
wouldn't be able to buy like I have to
be at least 240 for me to like be able
to move people still to even show up
who's the big guy oh Calais Campbell huh
hi sir how are you nice to meet you his
brother is uh uh his brother's a
comedian but um so I got to meet him a
couple of times and
um but yeah he's like a generalist giant
dude he's super super nice yeah he's a
cool guy I haven't met a ton of NFL
players but I got to see Brandon
Marshall at the Super Bowl real nice guy
he's cool too he's huge yeah he was very
tall I thought he was thick too white
coward at first dude yeah that's funny
but yeah that is like he's bigger than I
am too and he played wide receiver think
about that for a sec it's like Brandon
why do you just play tight end dude well
less money but I was like I mean you
could have probably played another
couple years why do y'all get less money
I don't know
let's figure that out you I'll call in
and you're gonna figure it out you're
doing more thank you
I never realized that or get get this so
um Travis Kelsey this guy 1300 yards 10
10 touchdowns a year for like the last
seven years basically but it gets more
ball thrown over than you sure but my
point is is that
if he was a wide receiver his contract
he'd be the 26th highest paid wide
receiver in the NFL does that make sense
no no he should probably be top five so
that's like I don't know he should
probably be making if like there's water
she was out there making over 25 million
dollars
that don't get his stats like why would
he not get paid more yeah right I mean
like I was I think I was 30 NFL in
touchdowns this year and yeah I mean
there's 20 receivers that make more
money than me
no yeah no I'm happy for them I'm I'm
happy right now they're making their
money it's them no it's nothing against
them it's just like that's the tie to
Market like our franchise tag is like 10
million dollars which is like if a team
doesn't like
um Evan Ingram tied in for the
Jacksonville drivers he was franchise
tag which means like they don't want to
do a new deal yet but they're going to
give you a one-year deal and it's based
on the average of like the top couple
contracts of your position it's like his
was 10 million dollars and then the
quarterback franchise tag is 30 million
dollars for that one season
and I get the quarterback is the most
right that's the most important position
but like wide receiver franchise tag is
I want to say like 20 something was like
are they really double the value no I
don't think so especially yeah I don't
think no I don't especially now when
you're getting all these however you
have like taste them Hill you have a
hybrid player that could possibly do it
all yeah sure like and like no now the
thing when you get and
you you have to be great at all those
things for it to be a value of you in a
contract negotiation too right that's a
good point yeah so you have to be great
like
if you and if you can just if you can
just do several things but you do them
averagely
I'd rather have like a guy that does
this great and a guy that does this
great than having a guy that does it
both average right that's a big Point
yeah so like that's a part of it too but
it's just like is there is there a
position that we don't know that you
could possibly play on the field that
people wouldn't really realize maybe oh
dude I would love to play like outside
linebacker in a 3-4 defense kind of like
I know I'm not gonna say like I'm not
gonna say off I'm going to be amazing at
it but I think I would have a real shot
at it if I could get up to like 260 265
maybe 270 and set an edge I think I'd do
that I'm a really good athlete and like
you don't have to run as much
which is really nice I get tired
sometimes dude oh I get tired of
watching thank you [__] get water ah
dude if you ever watched I I put the
auction mask on almost after every Drive
really I don't know if it does anything
I don't know if it does anything but I
do feel better like I'm just like ah
well even if it's a placebo effect I'm
big into Placebo effects if you believe
it that it works do it yeah is it
flavored the oxygen is it like grape ice
or anything
I'm gonna ask yeah you know next year
get some gas in there dog Riptide Rush
Gatorade I do something Glacier freeze
yeah salty caramel I don't know I'm also
named you're a sweet guy well I'm naming
vape flavors also I don't think I Vape
since College I did that for a hot sex
don't do it dude I know I know I was
listening to a couple of your podcasts
uh [__] suffering from I listen to
your Jay Cutler podcast that was fun did
you yeah I had to prepare a little bit
dog oh that's a good point man yeah Jay
kind of doesn't uh
I I can't believe Jay played quarterback
that long in the NFL I don't think Jay
can believe it
that's a good point you know it's funny
too so I'm a Bears fan I grew up in Iowa
there's no NFL team so like I grew up in
Chicago Bears fan Bears fan yeah so I
grew up Chicago Bears Cubs fan and uh
like I still like the Bears like I'm
still a fan of the Bears
um but like was it tough during the
Cutler years
he brought a lot of excitement to it
like he really did like he would have
games where you throw for like 350 yards
and four touchdowns it was really fun to
watch a fun bearded Bears fan like
Plenty Of Heartbreakers but like yeah I
enjoy Jay color the memes of him like
having a cigarette in his mouth at the
podium like those are one of my those
are some of my favorite football memes
because because he was like he was the
first person that they made those memes
about was him with the like just
cigarettes like just smoking cigarettes
he's a regular dude he's just a regular
dude Jay Cutler's a regular dude man
like I'll see him at a bar or see him at
like a party or something and he's uh
he's just like
you would almost yeah you wouldn't even
get I don't know if you wouldn't guess
it'd be I don't know
but yeah he's just a most regular dude
he's just like that's the crazy thing
about NFL players most of us are just
regular dudes do do there be are there
still players that smoke cigarettes you
think
like you ever been out there you're like
Jesus somebody's been [__] smoking at
halftime
um I had a teammate my rookie season who
after practice and after games would
smoke cigarettes and
yeah I I you know what I'm not going to
tell say who it is but there was we lost
my rookie year we lost in Lambeau uh
Aaron Rodgers did like a 30-second drive
to kick a field goal to win the game and
I guess when we were 0-9-2 so like we
almost win the lambo and one as like my
rookie class in it they were a much
better team than this but we somehow
kept it close and like losing that and I
had a good game too but like it was a
heartbreaker and like like I said I grew
up a Bears fans like playing in Lambo
for the first time in a night game like
it was really cool yeah it was a cool
experience like you want to win those
games so losing and I go to the shower
and he's in there smoking a cigarette
and I was like hey man I'll take one of
those if you don't mind man hopefully I
don't get in trouble for that like I
don't know like that's probably illegal
but I'm sorry NFL don't get mad at me
but I did do that one time and it was
that was a really fun one and like one
of the coaches walked in like looked at
us and just walked out of the shower so
I was like yeah dude give us a second
man just chilling look it's
probably nude men smoking cigarettes
you're not wrong it was yeah bro it's
Russia
let them have their moment they just
lost again will you give me a sec please
oh there should be eight minutes we
should be allowed to smoke a cigarette
after the game I think if your team
loses
um are there quarterbacks that you
wouldn't be excited to play for do you
feel like oh excited to play for well
let's just do this how about non-verbal
communication you don't have to say
anything okay I'll rattle off a couple
names right
um and what do you want me to do you
don't have to say you don't have to do
anything okay just look just look okay
I'm looking forward all right
Andy Dalton did the red rocket
Deshawn Watson
Jim Marcus Russell
Jamarcus the tape guy remember that they
gave him fake tapes that's crazy see the
only way
it would be as a teammate
for him to do that that would piss me
off about me out that would bum me out
like I'll give anybody an opportunity
like I don't care who the like I don't
like if you if you put your effort in
and you show up and you play and like
you did everything you could to be
prepared and you have a bad game I'm not
gonna hate you for that right if you
tried but like if you go out of your
like if you don't like try and get up
here yeah if you're not professional
it's your job like that's the crazy
thing like in college you have to do
classes and like you're a very your
testosterone field 20 year old like you
have other things in your life that
might at that time matter more than
football if you're in the NFL like yes
your family matters and like there's
certain things but like it's your job
it's your profession and you're you have
all you have 60 other guys in that
locker room who are counting on you to
do your job oh yeah and for you to do
that yeah like I wouldn't appreciate
that so that's that's something I would
that would piss me off yeah something
like that would really upset me I think
yeah do what you're supposed to do well
like my goal is to win a Super Bowl I
like proven an NFC Championship game I
can't help much if I can't get the ball
thrown to me yeah we didn't have a
quarterback so could should somebody do
who who was the last quarterback to go
in he has lost a couple quarterbacks so
you guys lost your whole quarterbacks
all year yeah so fun fact uh I've played
six years NFL and four out of this I've
had one quarterback for one season one
time 2019 I had Jimmy G for one season
and we went to the Super Bowl
um my rookie year we had three
quarterbacks my second year we had three
quarterbacks he had Nick Mullen one time
too love Nick Mullins yeah he's CJ
beathard yeah he is oh yeah I'm a fan
man he lives in Franklin Tennessee oh he
does yeah he's part of the reason I live
here he was one of my boys sorry we
played five years together in Iowa and
then four years together in San
Francisco she's one of my best friends
oh that's cool man it seems like a
really neat guy oh he's wonderful but he
uh so like my second year I had three
quarterbacks 2020 I had three
quarterbacks 2021 I had two quarterbacks
in this past season I had four
quarterbacks [__] your bad luck
how hard was it when like did um
or fourth quarterback was Josh by the
way great dude Joshua Josh Johnson that
was the last guy who got hurt that was
the last guy that got hurt and then so
after that who was there was there any
talk or that somebody else could go in
there so like you like you you
tentatively game plan for like an
emergency quarterback and Kyle you check
our fullback was our emergency
quarterback but like
there's only like
he doesn't know the footwork stuff for
plays like the Playbook was like
foreplay like four to eight plays
because it's crazy because Shane coach
Shanahan Kyle Shannon he's been NFL like
I want to say like 15 to 20 years like
being a part of coaching in it and he's
never had it happen to him his dad Mike
Shanahan never never seen it because he
can't even text his dad at halftime what
do I do like he never experienced it
either and then we have our running
backs coach he's like he's in you're
like 60 and he's never seen it either
like at any level and so it's just like
it doesn't happen often so like you're
mild and everyone's like well why aren't
you more prepared because it doesn't
happen you're not prepared but were you
guys like looking around the sideline
like who's even lean enough here to even
throw you know what I'm saying like
because at that point it's also like a
stat you can't have like the only thing
that I wanted to see just for like even
at the point because like for kicks yeah
after after Josh got hurt like and we
were down and like it's like at that
when Josh got hurt where I think we're
only down set like we might have been
down seven or no we were down 21 to 70.
excuse me when he got hurt and so at
that point you're like okay we can't
throw we like the next couple like
you're like okay we might have a shot
here but I think they went down and
scored it's 28-7 and you're just like we
can't physically throw the football and
they're just gonna put 11 people in the
Box
all right like sure like how creative
can you get I know uh Juwan Jennings one
of our wide receivers he played at
Tennessee he was like a top five
quarterback recruit in high school which
was kind of so like maybe I wanted to
see that but like at the end of the day
like you're not gonna it's not high
school where you just put your best
athlete at quarterback or college where
you can just put a really fast guy
quarterback can you just run around the
edge and do cool stuff like
that doesn't exist in the NFL like it
just doesn't happen right there's too
many good athletes so it's like
should have been like hey if you would
have got him in and like we would have
thrown the ball he throws interception
it is what it is like right we're like
you trying every you can to not like oh
we're gonna lose this game but it's like
we the most important position we don't
have yeah okay what's up it's like
playing chess you don't have a king oh
you lost yeah like I mean the only other
team do is the Denver Broncos during
covert they had all their quarterbacks
had coven and so he put a wide receiver
in but they had a week to prepare at
least or a couple days at least but it's
just like what are you supposed to do
yeah damn it was such a bummer man I'm
so sorry it wasn't even fun to watch no
and like hey if you're an Eagles
football player an Eagles fan probably
loved it and good like you should like I
don't even think you love it like but
like you enjoy something like that then
you're sick too sure I wouldn't hate
that dude well like they brought they
loved winning but like winning in that
way is like it's not exciting right like
if there's nothing like there's not
really anything exciting about that no
if you're cheering then or [__] yeah
it's like sure like hey you guys are
scoring like they're winning the game
and they're beating like yeah there's
not much you're beating somebody who's
like hands are tied behind their back
and like hey they won and they yeah
you're not saying no but I don't feel
you like at least it would have been an
entertaining game oh yeah if like even
if like well they should their
quarterback out both of them that'd be
wild if they go well how about this
that's insane I shouldn't even say that
do you think it's fair that the overtime
team just goes to kick that field goal
it seems kind of lame each time
liked for the win well that rule changed
like five years ago oh it did yeah so
that good so then it went to like you
got to if you score a touchdown you
automatically win and then this past
season in the playoffs in overtime both
teams get a chance uh whether it's a
touchdown or not because you remember
the bills Chiefs game from last year and
went back and forth and everyone's like
well if the bill like the offenses were
so high powered if the bills would have
gotten a shot they would have gone out
and scored so they changed the rule for
the playoffs if that happened that both
teams get an opportunity to add it which
was interesting to see yeah I think it's
more exciting it can make the game a
little bit longer it definitely makes it
more exciting as a fan I think I mean I
think college has overtime perfect like
just it's so much fun it's so much like
11th overtime yeah like that's 2 A.M and
then also like for the people watching
like those touchdowns count and like
there's multiple of those so it's like a
guy could go like what was like there's
like an LSU Ole Miss game that it was
like tied like 17 to 17 and it ended
53-48 or something like that or 53 to 47
some [__] like that but it's like a guy
in that game a wide receiver like at the
end of the game he had like five catches
for 60 yards and a touchdown at the end
of the game he had uh eight catches for
four touchdowns and a hundred yards
they're just like what where'd this come
from it's a four overtime so I think the
NFL should just start at the 35 yard
line because then if you go three now
it's still a 52-yard kick like that's
not easy right 52-yard like from the 35
and just have him do it that way it'd be
so much fun I mean just like you're just
taking shots for touchdowns at that
point man that's so sweet it'd be sick
dude yeah that'd be a buy like dude the
stats too like fantasy football players
Fantasy Football uh guys would love that
because hey now Devonte has at the end
of overtime where he has 10 catches for
122 touchdowns now he has 14 catches for
six touchdowns
they never even talk to their wives
anymore
do you think uh
and we'll get you out of here in a
second
um what was you were talking about like
um
uh uh oh do you think that
um who do you think will bl's
quarterback next year
um Brock will get a fair shot at it do
you think oh yeah I mean he didn't he
hasn't lost a game yet like he got hurt
at this for like oh yeah play the game
and so like he hasn't really lost a game
yet he should get it yeah I mean so it's
also a very competitive room over there
it's a super competitive room right now
we don't tray Lance I think he he just
got clear it's like he's out throwing
and stuff again so that's awesome I'm
very happy for him like because he is a
very he's a very special talent who has
the ability to be a very good football
player he just needs reps and that guy
he just he's young he hasn't played a
lot of football against he's reps oh
yeah so it'll be a good battle between
them
um well you'll still have him no he's a
free agent oh he's gonna leave probably
oh yeah he's out oh dang yeah so but
like what I like I think it's a um if
Brady came back would he be able to go
to y'all Or Not yeah he's a free agent
Debbie Wilde
that'd be wild huh yeah I mean he's from
the bay he is he is from the bay that's
crazy
interesting
anyways but um Purdy I like I said like
pretty 1A games you can't like bench you
can't you can't bench him so I think
it's a it's a it's a quarterback
competition I think when you go to like
and again but I can't win a game he's
doing just even better money line every
week it's crazy but like and I and again
like he's hurt right now right so I
think he just I think he got surgery
today maybe on his UCL which is like the
ACL of your elbow I guess oh they got a
third one now it's crazy dude wild stuff
um but so like he has to recover from
that so like it's gonna be it's gonna be
an interesting training camp to see how
the reps are split and stuff like that
it's gonna be exciting it will be
exciting and that's my entire my entire
career I've had QB controversy so let's
ride dude another year of it baby I love
it that's exciting bring it you you one
last thing for you I want to get you
were talking about like speaking things
into uh existence yeah you wanted to
bring it back that up yeah because you
kind of talked about it it's interesting
how little we like speak out into the
world what we want yeah like how like
how often do like I'll sit and complain
in my head or think about things or
worry bro all but for years yeah but
rarely will I say this is what I [__]
want yeah you know and so you're gonna
do it yeah so you're going to get it
yeah yeah like I'm big like I don't know
if you Journal very much but I got big
into that this literally like the last
12 months I met a former player who uh
who kind of talked about how he did it
too and like just writing down like what
you expect the season to be like what
your what your goals are or writing
about them in the past tense too that
was kind of a cool thing to like take me
give an example of that so like you
could talk about winning the Super Bowl
or you could talk about like I won the
Super Bowl yeah and you talk about
confetti fall and you talk about like
and you speak into existence like
there's a creativeness to it and so like
it's kind of why because then once you
see it and you've it's kind of like the
same as football like I do visualization
a lot so like I rep the plays in my head
and so then by the time I get to them in
practice or whether it's the game I've
already done them in my head like 10
times so when you call it play I'd have
nothing to worry about because I've
already done it and so it's like
speaking into existence too it's like
you visualize it happening and then so
like I don't know if you speak it into
existence or you're like once the moment
comes you're ready for it what's really
interesting man it makes me think of
EMDR you know have you heard of this
maybe I don't know explain it to me can
you bring it up
foreign
so EMDR eye movement decent side
desensitization and reprocessing therapy
is a mental health treatment technique
the method involves moving your eyes uh
goal is to help you heal from trauma or
other distress so anyway what's
interesting about EMDR is it they take
you back to times in your life right
that were traumatic for you and they you
you
you talk through with a therapist to
to put a new experience into that time
of your life yeah so then when you come
out of the the the like uh modality or
the the experience of doing EMDR the
therapy yeah
then the past
part of your life that was hurting you
it's now filled with a different part of
your life that's positive yeah for sure
so where you are at now currently will
eventually start to feel different
because the past the apostles have been
filled in that's crazy so it's almost
like a reverse of doing that which
you're saying yeah sure like you're
creating those right in the future and
so then by the time you get to them it's
like well you're looking back on your
past you're writing into your own past
that hasn't even happened yet yeah
you're writing your own past and saying
these things happen it's wow and like I
yeah like and I I did it every single
day for the entire season wow it's wild
and whether like whether your goals are
personally for the season whether it's
goals like whatever it is like kind of
talking about in the past tense it was
it's really weird like it's like to get
used to writing like that it's because
I've never done anything like that
before and so like that was a different
experience for me
um but you're talking about like that
type of therapy have you seen the type
of therapy that's like let's just say
you have like you go to therapy right
now and like everyone has certain
traumas in their life and the theory I
can't remember exactly what it's called
but it's like
like so 10 year old you something
happened right and like that version of
you like that version of you like the
state that you went into like to recover
from that is still a part of your
personality and right so like whether
it's like and like how you manage with
it so like okay so let me let's just say
you're uh 10 years is bad like so like
you're a 25 year old and some bad
happens and you turn to drinking or
something like that right and whenever
something bad happens you kind of go
back to that right you go back to that
because like that's your therapy for it
so like this goes into you've kind of
revisit you have a conversation with
that 25 year old you okay and you're
like and then you try to get them to
accept it because like you have these
different parts of you inside of you
like for these different experiences
whether it's like
um yeah like that type of experience or
like
I'm trying to explain it the best way I
can but it's like you have to have these
conversations with this old passive you
to kind of let go and like you kind of
hold on to stuff ah interesting so
you're going back to like an injured
part of you or an injured part of you
and you're trying to help them get
through it because like you can't talk
to it like it's to say you had a bad
call unless you had a really bad
experience in college like with a coach
or something like that and they like
verbally abused you right and like that
part of you is like still there like
it's it is still there unless you you go
to therapy you talk about like if you
just kind of hold on to it that part of
you is always still kind of like this
dark anger and so you have to kind of go
back there and talk to them and like
talk to that 18 year old self right like
almost making amends yeah with your old
or like guiding them to the light maybe
sort of Beats but like just kind of let
go of that anger because if you never
talk to it just kind of hold it on like
you can push stuff down for so long but
like at some point you gotta address it
yeah it says trauma can freeze your
emotional response at the age you
experienced it when you feel or act
emotionally younger than your actual age
as is known as age regression well it's
even the same as almost EMDR it's like
going back into a specific that's what
reminded me of it and I was like because
I know my dad talked to me about that
it's like a type of therapy you can do
like to overcome like traumatizing
events that happen to you and as it was
a very like I thought about it I was
like that actually makes sense to me
well your dad is really interesting man
I've seen some of the episodes where
he's like doing
um
hidden pearls you said it's called where
he'll do like he's like doing uh his
mindful Mondays right yeah mindful are
just like kind of like taking you
through an experience
um you can just see how it's part of his
uh you guys's whole world all that stuff
he's big into that like breathing
visualizing
um it just it helps dude like when you
just can take a second to yourself and
like just kind of breathe and like just
be one with whether it's your breath or
just like your own thoughts or something
like that because most of the time like
we're all oh man so scattered we're like
this you're on your phone you're
watching TV you're looking at opinions
of other people but like not too often
are you just kind of sitting there like
ah like just having that conversation
with yourself because you kind of need
to man like if you if you if you don't
like then you're not really progressing
as a human you're just kind of absorbing
everyone else's information and then
like is that who you are these days or
do you want to be your own person
and it's what's really interesting
George is that they've created it's so
hard it's so addictive they've mastered
the uh the uh our attention social media
is amazing they've mastered the art of
taking our attention it's incredible
like Tick Tock videos man you can go to
Rabbit Hole for two hours and not even
blink oh you don't even know who you are
you come out your [__] child's in the
Middle School yeah I'm like what just
happened like where is going on well
it's funny I was watching uh Chris
Rock's new special last night I haven't
seen it yet is it good it is cool man I
I didn't watch all of it but he's he
talks about your attention that's the
number one thing that um that people are
after these days yeah that sounds about
as your attention whatever you put your
attention into is how your life changes
I know so it's funny when I think of my
when I think in my head that like I'm
always a
constantly overwhelmed by different
thoughts and I feel sporadic and I can't
keep uh my attention span on anything
but then when I look at what a a tick
tock is it's literally what
oh this is just a thing of what I am
it's wild it's just like a bunch of
thoughts everything seems kind of
disorganized it's all in one place but
it's [__] feels I mean if you saw
Tick Tock you would give it
a antidepressant yeah dude it's knots
Tick Tock like this this is how social
media like in captures you like I mean
my wife always yells at me like I'll go
sit on the toilet and oh you won't come
back dude you're 30 minutes later like
what just happened
oh my God where was it why are my legs
asleep what has happened like what
goodness gracious but she's like you can
just get lost in those things so like I
refuse to get an Apple Watch because why
do I need to fall on my wrist if I have
one in my pocket oh it's crazy it's
crazy how about somebody have a fight
the other day with their son on an Apple
Watch through texting or something it
took them like an hour and a half to
even have the fight and it was a guy
I've seen guys on my team that wear
Apple watches out to like walk through
practices and like you're not at home
you're not like it's like it's just
learning like plays and stuff like
they'll have it on like I'll be in the
huddling guy next like he'll be like you
know I'll heal vibration he'll look I'm
like what do you like are you on your
phone at a walk through like what are
you doing he goes uh I just it tracks my
heart rate why do you need to track your
heart rate right now dude you're jogging
like relax like take your Apple out
watch off disconnect for a little bit
it's okay like see I I have a calculator
on my watch oh you got that old school
Amazon I love it they have it on there
yeah dude so get this this was 30 I
bought on Amazon and like I I've worn
the entire season I love it I like kind
of I talked about like on a podcast one
time I went back to Amazon to buy
another one because I forgot I thought I
lost this one eighty dollars so I don't
know if I'm just hyping them up for some
reason or something like that but yeah
80 so it's 80 bucks but still like
that's a pretty good price for a gold
watch yeah it is but still I feel like
it almost seems sometimes I feel like it
knows what you've been shopping for if
you shop for something expensive
recently it will make tickets more
expensive for you for things I mean like
I'll talk you'll talk about hey I need
deodorant and seven dollars I scroll
through I scroll through Instagram and
the third there's an ad and it's for Old
Spice I'm like yeah what the heck I
talked about this 10 minutes ago why is
there it's just listening dog or if you
even think about killing your cousin or
something and the [__] next thing you
know is just all hammers
dude it's crazy even having an apple
watches so it's like it'll tell you now
like you just coughed and here said the
dude's like oh I just coughed you know
they're just like you needed a yeah do
you need DayQuil launch belch in 30
seconds yeah it's dude it's nuts man
it's too much man yeah cause I like War
I wore one I didn't get an Apple Watch
but I wear the Garmin watch that like
tracks a lot of your stuff and like like
a lot of triathlon Runners running
because like they have to know all their
stuff all the time and I was like after
a while I was like you know what the
only thing I really care about is like I
like seeing my sleep so like I have that
the aura ring stuff and I like seeing my
sleep because I either there's like it
tells you how long you slept it tells
you how well you slept and right so this
is my mind so like whether if I get like
green in one of those areas
hey I'm gonna have a good day because
whether let's say I got seven hours of
sleep and that's red but I
90 of those super good deep sleep
healthy you're like okay I'm gonna have
a great day today or if they're both in
the red my mindset is now all right I
didn't give myself a good advantage
today so I gotta try a little bit harder
today because it's gonna be a harder day
because I didn't sleep well and I didn't
get a lot of hours and so like that's
like people are like well I don't like
to see them like why it's just another
challenge that you get to accomplish
today well that's it I mean I think that
almost sums up just your entire approach
man you're lucky that you are not lucky
I mean obviously you know a lot of it
comes from your own family experience
and
so maybe some of your parents and stuff
but because a lot of people I get that
number I'd see that 60 out of 100 or
whatever
[__] I'd start texting [__] you to
everybody right out of the gate you know
and I'd even text myself [__] you I feel
you no I know I don't know but then I
would let it ruin me as opposed to me
saying okay today's gonna be a little
bit more of a challenge it's an uphill
challenge guys it's uphill boy it's like
well like so I mean when you're in like
like right now I'm in the off season
right so like one my competitive my
competitive switch is much lower than
when I'm in season
um but like when you're in season and
it's a Tuesday night and I have to wake
up and I have like I have six hours of
meetings before I go do a walk through
and then I have to go do a practice of
plays that I learned at 8 A.M that
morning and I have to study those plays
before practice like those six hours
like
I can't be off right like that's I can't
be like I can't let my guy I can't let
the guy next to me down and I'm my
expectation for him is that he's
whenever he can to be as prepared as he
can so like you don't have enough you
don't have an option to be off and so
like that's how I that so you have to
find different ways to encourage
yourself and so hey hey I slept eight
hours and it's good I'm gonna have a
great day today or if it's one's bad
one's good hey one of them's green I'm
gonna be great and the last one's like
all right well I'm just gonna kick my
own ass today like bring it and like
it's like that's that's what my mindset
has to be now off season yeah I might
[__] and moan a little bit more but
like it is what it is like I only have
so many off days as like I only have so
many days anyways so like I'm gonna I'm
just gonna keep going yeah I think you
got to give yourself some breaks here
and there I mean even if you don't even
if you have a job that doesn't really
even allow that many you know and you
know you're gonna take them when you can
get them it's a high con it's a high
competition level you're in it's a high
competition uh profession yeah you got
to take them when you can get them man
well I'm gonna
um say thank you for coming
and I appreciate it dude and it it's uh
it's a it's been exciting just to hear
about just some of your thoughts and get
to know you a little bit better and um
yeah I'm so happy for you and your
success thank you and oh tell us about
tiny and you I wanted to hear about it
oh yeah because last year I heard tying
you was going on right and I [__]
wanted to meet everybody like Jeremy
Holt didn't text me back so I literally
parked in the parking lot where you guys
were practicing Vanderbilt oh Drake
contexted me right yeah Drake was the
ball Lipscomb although it sounds two
years ago yeah Lipscomb oh two years ago
at Lipscomb so yeah I'm like you could
have showed up man I would have gone you
in oh well [__] honestly dude I may have
been outside of some other conference
there because I was there
I was there let's go this year dude no
joke
yeah we're really yeah oh God yeah then
it was something else going on but
but I was texting though I was texting
Jeremy I was texting Drake they said we
were in a place where they couldn't get
good reception right yeah for sure but I
was outside of a group of men who were
like just stretching and I was like just
kind of being sat in my truck outside of
Lipscomb but um because I wanted to come
up and just like just be around and just
see what was going on yeah you want to
come through this year yeah man June
20th is our welcome party it's on a
Tuesday night okay so that's our welcome
party it's at the top of the Thompson
Hotel oh nice and it's really fun um
yeah all the Titans are up there uh it's
just literally it's just getting no guys
that are around it's really it's a fun
event and then Wednesday Thursdays on
the field stuff at Vanderbilt and then
Wednesday night we have like a function
uh somewhere on Broadway and then maybe
12 30 club or something like that we're
working on the details and then uh
Thursday's a work day and then but it's
like it's really it's really fun but
yeah if you want to swing through for
you know Wednesday the Tuesday night
thing or more than welcome to yeah
that'd be cool I don't want to invite
now I feel bad like I invited myself you
didn't man Drake invited you okay great
yeah Jimmy John does uh he was on this
podcast Jimmy John liato he's I met her
of 12 30 Club yeah yeah no I met so
there was I told my mother-in-law she
works for the NFL honor of NFL Hall of
Fame health and they have an event and
it's at the 12 30 club and it's there
again this year but this is funny so
they were auctioning off footballs and
there's like I think there was like six
to ten NFL guys that were there but uh
one of the footballs I got auctioned off
he bought it and it was signed by
um Eddie George and George Kittle oh
cool probably the only football ever
signed by us too but the fact that his
last name is my first name I just you
don't see that very often but I thought
that was pretty funny but yeah I met him
at that event it was pretty funny yeah
that's in that's I guess that's kind of
interesting I guess but this is an
excite you too yeah
I mean I just George is in a very common
name so when I see other people with it
it excites me I guess that's true and
that's very fair actually and I
shouldn't have said that thank you I
feel bad about myself yeah I don't want
to do this anymore will you guys cover
the entire thing but is Joe George still
of hop George isn't that popular of a
name anymore is it no it's old
everyone's like when I was George when I
was eight years old I was like you're an
old man no I'm not I'm a real boy
people were like [__] old people yeah
I'm like leave me alone I'm not 50 yeah
I'm in hospice
George is most popular in the western
industry is ranked in the top 200 most
popular names since its origin origin I
believe that both of my great grandpas
were named George and that's why I named
George tough my parents told me if I was
a girl they would have named me Georgia
I don't think that's a very good name
nothing against those people out there
named Georgia just not for me yeah I
feel your Eddie Georgia that's insane oh
dude's got two first names
um George Kettleman best of luck in your
next season man enjoy your time welcome
back home and uh and enjoy your time
I'll see you Lipscomb in your off season
Praise Baby oh thank you so much it's
been a pleasure this is really fun yeah
it's been fun man thank you
[Music]
this piece of my life I found I can feel
it in my bones
gonna take